Hello, hello, everyone.
Hello.
I might have fucked up a little bit last night.
I may or may not have played Vampire Crawlers till 5 in the
morning.
I kept going.
I had only one more run.
Just until after I complete the stage.
It was until after I complete this area.
And I was like, oh, this might be the last area this looks
very end like end game but after I complete this area and
then I'll be done I'll be finished with the game and then I
unlocked another area and it's like oh okay this looks like
end game after this run I'll get to bed I'm gonna head to
bed after this run and then I died and I was like no I must
beat this run I must beat this area after after beating this
area I will
And my boy Bones is gonna take me to the end.
He's gonna take me all the way.
He's gonna take them to the Bone Zone.
Anyway, so then I saw it was 5 a.m.
And I finally, I beat the area.
And then it unlocked another area.
And I was like, oh, dude.
I was just like.
Oh, there's more.
It never ends.
There's always more areas to unlock.
More levels to unlock.
So, yeah, I get it now.
I get how the devs used to make slot machines for casinos.
I get it now.
They got it.
got their game is it pay to win okay there's no gotcha
there's no real life money in their games thank fucking god
because that would be a real problem i they got me they
actually got let me show you how much i progressed since
don't worry it's still a convenience stream i i was so
tempted that i was this close to change today's stream to
vampire crawlers i was like no i can't i can't do that to
them also i can't do that to me because when i was playing i
was literally just locked in and all i could think about are
the cards i was so locked in and i was like that was just
like i was just mute and just go like click click click
click click click click click click click click click i need
that concentration and focus to beat the game anyways so
look at these are these are all the characters i remember
when it was just two rows it was one row and a half um
there's a dog in this game now anyway i'm mr bone i'm bone
zone here i'm more to more to chico or whatever his name is
um so this this one sucks this one was my other bianca i
used to did i did bianca at first and i unlocked mr bones
and i was like that's him That's him, alright.
He's my guy.
Give us a round for the road.
You can have three crawlers?
What do you mean?
I got three guys?
But this is my guy.
I just use him.
I don't care about the others.
Like, it works.
If it works, it works.
I don't need to change my strategy.
And then, here's the shop.
I got everything here.
I just go all in on XP.
max health and damage that's all i need it's a power one run
for a little treat yet just one game oh don't tempt me for a
good time guys don't we're gonna say one run and then i'll
be we'll be like how about one more dokey how about and it's
like oh now that you're here anyway might as well just
complete the area and i'm like that's a brilliant idea
anyway so i finished look at that i finished and all of the
forest.
And then the teeny bridge.
I mean, I did not finish the milk factory.
Oh, I could do the milk factory.
I finished dairy plant.
Wow, it was, who would have thought it was so much easier
when you're not on fucking pole?
I finished the weeny bridge, the weeny hut junior bridge.
I did gallo tower.
And then meeny bridge.
And I thought meeny bridge was the end.
And then now, now we have the fucking church.
I guess I went in here.
I died.
Okay.
To be fair.
I did do one more.
I did.
I was like, okay.
What if I one shot this round?
I was like, I was like, oh, what if, what if this is the
last area?
I'm going to run shot this.
And then, and then I died.
I, Mr. Bones got sent back to hell.
He was not meant to be in heaven.
All right.
We'll do one quick run.
One quick run before we start our shift.
Don't worry.
My boss can understand.
um the 7-eleven can be closed for a little longer it's okay
i'm not opening up the store anyway so like the other guy
can uh can work on my shift a little longer don't worry all
right one just one more run yeah it's okay it just one more
um just play since you're here already mr broken bot thank
you super chat thank you thank you covo and slide they give
us a 10 and 5 gift the ships, they can thank you.
It's alright, I got someone to cover for me, guys.
It's okay.
Alright, watch this.
It's like, so all I do is bones and then more bones.
Because they can't do that to us, like, we don't want to
watch you play this.
They get super challenging out of these.
Alright, fuck this cat.
Alright, don't fuck the game, but fuck this cat.
The cat is such a useless ability.
Alright.
I just bash my head until I see something.
Alright, watch this.
Bones!
And then more bones!
And then they don't die.
I just sent in more bones
That is fun Also, I have the thing where I have like to
because I realize I keep If I don't have armor, I just die
Is that crazy concept?
That's such a crazy concept.
So what I said did is that I have the armor persist stat so
I just stock up on armor so I can just keep throwing bones
for the rest of my life and then I don't have to worry about
anything I just keep throwing bones and it works it's it
always works just keep throwing the bones eventually I'll
kill them okay there we go oh yeah hope would never do that
Why did I bring an old man to a fucking dairy plant?
And then...
Just one run.
What a coward, Mr. Broken Pod.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lolly, thank you, Super Chat.
You say you can't do that to us.
Like, we don't want...
Oh, yeah, we already read that.
Sorry.
I'm thinking... All I can think about our bones.
Alright.
Oh, I can't involve this already.
Alright, fuck this.
Alright, I'll grab another armor.
okay don't worry I could this will be a fast run guys and
then we'll go to our convenience store guys do not worry
this will be a really fast run okay and then I could do more
bone more bone just just more bone don't worry it's gonna be
a speed run guys look how fast I'm going oh fuck what did I
get what did I get
I went too fast!
What happened to the...
What happened to the chest?
I guess we'll never know.
It was too fast.
Oh.
There we go.
Someone said more bone.
Oh, I cashed out.
Alright, that's fine.
I'll take the money.
More bone!
Look at that.
Poe could never.
More bone.
Just keep throwing bones at the problem.
Okay, I might need armor.
I realize that I might need armor, guys.
I might.
Oh my god.
My entire field relied on armor and I sold...
I used my only armor.
Oh, this is bad.
Dude, I relied all on armor!
What armor?
It's God!
Oh, never mind, I still, I got it.
That's fine.
Maybe I'll have armor here.
Whoops.
I guess not.
I guess I'll just grab the recovery.
Oh, nice crown.
We actually need that.
there you go it's fine i literally beat a level eight uh
level seven area oh triple damage you know where i put that
on on the bone and all i need to do is find a mirror and
then all of them will just be x3 bones it's just that easy
look at that one bone
i knew it was a bad idea to send a Fucking retired man to a
back to war
He looks different.
It's just one quick run guys He'll be super fast.
We're almost done anyway.
Do not worry Look, Steve.
We're over at the end.
We're almost at the end guys.
Look at that.
He's right here.
Okay, see I told you I'll grab my armor again Alright, nice
Yeah, armor, I'm gonna grab the armor, and then duplicator.
Yeah, we'll send in more bones, and then we'll send in the
HP, and then more bones.
And then did someone say, more bones?
Oh my god, he's still alive, but don't worry, I still have
one more bone in there.
Okay, he's living way too long.
I don't like it.
Alright.
And then I just keep sending bones.
Just keep on sending bones.
There we go!
There we go.
That's what I like to see!
Okay.
Armors strike.
Your armor is damaged when played.
create coin hunt mana cost reduced when not used i don't
know i'm gonna banish the coin we don't need coins well we
do need coins but this is not a coin run this is me
finishing this game run
there we go look at that you don't know what to do they
enter the bone zone do you want to get off mr.
bones wild ride but there's no there's no such thing as
getting off this ride you're here forever I've got more XP
oh my god if I okay so my strat here is that I find like an
XP tone and then I put it on the bone my strength is your
shield I don't know what he does but I'm gonna buy you so
all I do is like I just keep throwing bones my the one the
meta I I did the men I did for it was that I put all the X
the XP tomes on the bones so I had two XP tomes all the but
on all the bones and I had 945 percent XP every game
945 XP percent there was nothing stopping me I was so strong
and I Still almost died.
I don't know how to fuck.
I still almost died there.
It was like the last boss, the Galileo guy.
In the little tower thing.
I did four attempts.
I do four fucking attempts until it worked.
No!
It was perfect, but I foned too hard.
I could have had more XP.
I got so greedy.
I was like, I can make this combo even higher.
I could have made it so high.
It's over-boned.
I wanted to keep boning.
I boned too close to the sun.
Suffering from success.
It was so...
many bones
okay what's that?
That is a lot of XP 190, I did it I did my combo
and then doesn't matter I don't need this anyway okay I need
more I don't remember if I need more 1s or 2s 0s 1s oh maybe
2s okay
there we go yeah overkill give me your chest give it to me
please i stopped i stopped to go to work all right let's
grab another lightning ring
please you're gonna write me up if i'm late one for one more
day I don't understand.
I thought it was strike six and you're out.
I still have like one more.
Alright, nice.
I feel like light kill him anymore.
Alright.
We got this.
We're speedrunning through this.
This is nothing to me.
Okay.
Alright, one more.
They're not dying fast enough.
They should die in one turn.
Alright, see, look at that.
That's why I do the armor shit.
She's so high before her freaking death.
We'll grab.
Do I need more ones or twos?
I don't know.
I keep losing camp.
There's so many cards.
Grab a two in there.
Oh, fuck.
It's alright.
We don't need the chicken anyway.
Sure, times three.
Okay, plus two.
Retain.
Okay, let's see it.
Draws another.
Increases mana cost.
Okay, but what if we...
We draw another bone.
It's your store manager.
Do I have a bone to pick with you?
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because I'm doing a billion job, right?
Because I'm doing such a good job.
Right, guys?
You know it's probably a good thing that Doki doesn't
actually have to get up.
Before nine and five, don't she even laugh?
That's a lot.
Look at that.
Boom!
It's just a scratch.
Don't worry, I can regen it.
And then bone, and then bone.
And did they say more bones?
I'm just, I'm literally just missing the XP tome.
If I have the XP tome, it just goes hard.
Got more mana.
All right, let's see.
Bone, two, three, and then bone.
And then we use bone again.
Nice.
All right.
Yeah.
And then bones.
Look at them go.
Oh, look at them go.
Look at them.
Yes!
Bones!
So many bones!
So, Toki, do you recommend that game?
It's alright.
It seems alright.
Okay.
Uh, oh my god, there it is.
Alright.
Uh, I'm gonna grab that, too, just for fun.
We're gonna have to...
Bone.
And then water.
Super bone!
What's better than normal?
Normal phone?
Super phone.
Boom, I'll go.
Too much bone.
There's no such thing.
Blastomy!
Get him out of here!
Out there, he said that.
There's no such thing as too many bones.
If anything, there's not enough!
Ha ha ha ha Here's it Bone apocalypse I hope the world burns
with bones
Or is it oh there it is
Where the fuck is that oh there it is Like where is the
item?
And we'll get the boss and then we'll do the chest
and then Antonio 10 more damage 10% more damage right here
it came just in time
there we go
and then drag another bone to me and then another bone and
then water
okay so I have 15 armor you can't do anything to me We'll
grab that, two, three, and then we'll grab another thing,
and then bone, bone, and then more bone.
And then, and then what should we do next guys?
Did someone say more bone?
Who said that?
Oh, grab the cross.
All right.
Give me my shit.
Oh, my God.
I can, oh, my God.
I can put this on the phone.
Oh, my God, I missed 20 minutes.
I'm streaming for playing Vampire Crawling.
This Doki is playing it too.
You can never escape.
All right.
What do I get rid of?
Wait, I don't have anything to get rid of, guys.
I could get rid of the cross.
You know what?
The cross and the water.
They have no purpose here.
They have no purpose.
Get these guys out of here.
Alright.
And then more bones.
More of those are bones.
What am I going to do with this?
Maybe we should get How dare who said that?
Fandoms!
I know.
Jokey, don't fathom.
Don't fathom.
We'll give him a warning.
And then if he does.
And then if he says that again.
We'll fathom.
If he doesn't learn his lesson.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, we gotta get a 2 and a 3 to replace the 2 and the 3 I
gave up.
Don't worry.
I put like a.
A sign there that said I'll be right back after my lunch
break.
Do you think I'm at lunch right now?
They're like, uh, please come back after after lunch and
then Do that and then bone and I track and then there you go
A three day.
Yeah, I have put the sign up three days ago.
I don't think they notice I can track another one and that
means another bone and I could do that and then I'll grab
that in here and then it's number three and then number four
and then magic and then a little bit stronger all right and
then zero one two grab another card zero zero all right
these don't matter it's between 20 years, toky.
Uh...
Oh, my God.
What can get rid of?
I'll get rid of this.
It's okay.
I can find another three.
I need more mana for my zero mana bones.
It's so important, guys.
You don't understand.
Oh, my God.
And that could just go in to that.
See, I I told you, look at that.
I got another three.
Nah, birds and bones.
I can't be stopped.
All the ad spam.
Okay.
Magic.
This.
And then 200 damage.
And then...
Attract.
Magic!
Fucking two birds!
There we go.
They replaced everything I need.
It's so cozy, guys.
Yeah, it's a new cozy game.
Everybody's playing it right now.
I feel so cozy right now.
Oh wait.
I'm gonna drag another bone with me.
And then let's just send him in.
Finish the job.
Get the bird in here.
Just poop on him.
Okay.
Grab two.
Lightning.
And then magic.
Ah.
Well, I'll send in a knife here.
It's no bone, but it got the job done.
And then Antonio, and then worm bones, and then...
Oh shit, that's the boss.
Why is he here?
Okay.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
The moment, oh no, okay.
Okay, one, and then minus one.
All right, I stocked up on the armor so you can't do
anything to me It's bone on bone violence when will it stop
Oh my god wait he touched me wait what oh wait a minute
that's not supposed to happen Did perhaps I added too much
bone no no I in fact I think I did add enough bones.
Yeah, weighty tome, axe.
We'll grab, we'll grab a brace.
So we can have more cards in our hands for more bones.
Never enough.
Okay, armor strike.
Okay, we can't have a knife.
Alright, never mind.
JK.
Just have swords now.
Oh my god, thank God I found that chicken.
I really needed it so badly.
You know what?
I should be left side doke.
You don't need to look at HP.
Nothing's going on there.
Nothing's going on on the HP department.
Let's just say.
There's three.
And then four.
And then we ended on bone.
What do you mean?
Turn two.
It's always my turn
It's like, yeah, wait till I get to play
Okay We'll grab spinach just for fun And this
Trash orb.
Then we got two more in the armor.
He's dead in the birds!
Enemies turn.
What's that?
It's always Jokey's turn.
Cash out.
Goodbye.
Yeah.
And then two, bone, bone.
So stupid, I can't believe.
Alright, but you know what?
I could put this?
Oh, I can't.
What's the point?
I might as well grab a...
Plus, draw a card.
So, draw a bow.
Okay.
One, two, three.
And then...
And then get the ring in.
Oh, no.
Wait, they touched me.
me all right i got this two three and then bone and then
bone i never went off mr bones wild pride i lived in i got a
mortgage and i
can grab that and grab that a bone all right that's good i
have 10 armor now i might actually need to grab more armor
Okay, nice, that's fine.
What's up, 11 there?
Light Tome, Light Dilling Ring, and then Magic.
Alright, give me my extra cash.
I'm only missing the XP Tome on this run.
That's the only one.
Oh my god.
Do I have more?
No!
I guess a bird will do.
Ain't no bone, but I guess it'll do.
It's not the same, guys.
It's not the same rush, you know?
Grab the brace.
Doesn't feel as good.
And
then...
Alright, next up.
Who's next?
That's right.
You saw what I did to your friends there?
That's fucking right.
Oh, bro.
Grab a duplicator.
So we can throw more.
Is this...
Yeah, yeah, this is.
This is me on my lunch break from the convenience store.
So technically it...
Technically, it still is.
I'm just on my lunch break right now, guys.
Okay.
Armor.
Grab that.
And then grab this.
Two.
Three.
And then we get another bone in there.
Yeah, you know how some stores, the employees have like
their own...
see your phone and they're just sitting there playing on
their phones this would be a really good phone game
grab that just chuck that in there too i don't even know
what numbers we're missing anymore fucking pick these guys
out all right let's grab here oh it's like it's a it's a
mini game and incoveni guys that's what it is if it looks
very much like incoveni yeah it very much looks like Vampire
crawler, it's just that there's like a little PC and
Inconveni and when you get on it, it just goes to vampire
crawlers They're doing like a little collab right now with
them Fuck yeah, I'll grab the 3x Oh my god, I got another
combo Yeah, I'm in the path you're playing on my phone
They'll be like, I'll be there for you just a minute
Don't worry
okay uh we'll reroll this none of this is good oh all right
let's just fuck it let's just add more mana i don't even
know what the what oh my god they have chickens now
and say what am i gonna do with mana and i was like wait i
actually do need mana
oh wait where are my bones oh Oh, there it is.
You scared me for a second there.
Holy shit.
These are some tanky-ass chickens.
Oh, never mind.
They're gone now.
They got evaporated.
Is that enough?
No, I have to skip that.
There we go.
Okay, we gotta grab that wagon.
Alright, more brace.
That's good.
That gives me chance to draw more bones.
As always.
And then.
Oh no!
There's no future and no future!
Okay, let's just grab this.
Oh, never mind.
JK.
There is a future.
Oh, look at them all go.
I'm just going to send this in.
He's gonna die regardless.
Zero, one.
And one.
Isn't Wing's wild card really good?
I don't want to do math.
I don't want to do math right now.
I just want to throw my bones.
That's all I want to do.
see that requires me to start counting and I know what I'm
here for I know my purpose no read no maps only chucking the
bones yes yes all right nice 2,000
Yes!
It's all coming together!
Send in more!
Zero.
One.
Two.
Okay, more projectiles.
Zero.
One.
Two.
One!
Full combo!
Uh, you don't want more mana.
Might as well.
Oh my god, there's too many cards now.
I'm losing count.
Bam!
It's alright, it's an alright game.
It's alright.
Okay, magic.
Light.
More.
Three.
Bone.
Okay, junk.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I have no attacks on here.
Oh, wait, I do.
Okay.
Nice.
It is unfortunate I pulled.
I just pulled two attack cards now.
Bone.
Put the junk in.
Why don't we just pull another bone in there?
Entered.
And I end my turn.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck it.
You know what?
You're gonna die.
It's just one guy.
All right, save your life.
No need to thank me.
No need to thank me, princess.
Join Papia.
All in a good day's work.
Oh, your neighborhood bones.
There's...
Track another one.
And then what if...
I draw this, and I do this, and then I do this, and then I
do this.
Where did they all go?
I thought there was 50 of you guys.
Did they all guys leave?
I don't know, any armor or friendship.
You know what, friendship?
Okay.
There we go.
Two combo.
Yeah, I thought so too.
I think this is the last one.
Maybe?
I'm not sure.
One.
And then we'll have all the armor for the future.
Okay.
We're going to suck in some bones.
And then...
another bone attack.
And send in the birds.
And have an extra armor just for the ride.
And then brace.
This.
Oh shit.
Alright.
Magic.
And then bird.
Bird on bird violence.
My favorite type of violence.
Do we attract another one?
Oh no!
I'm so confused.
Okay.
That's right, if all the birds start fighting each other, I
will remain the top bird.
Then there will only be me left.
I'll be the only bird left!
Yay!
The bird royale!
And it has a bullshit go.
Oh my god, wait!
Oh, I couldn't make a super bird though.
Oh my god, put maybe a triple.
Put super bird.
Oh my god.
I'll do it.
Super bird.
Use the birds.
Alright, oh anyway, it doesn't matter.
I'm dead.
Alright, there we go.
We got one run.
See, it was that easy.
It was so...
See, guys?
Look at that.
So easy.
All right, let's go back to work, guys.
Yeah, let's go back in it.
Whoa, what a long line of customers here.
Doug, thank you for the genta soup, but thank you.
But what if you just did one more run?
There's enough time before work starts.
I should get back to work, guys.
Madra won't be happy if he sees this line.
All right, also, Samya, let me know.
the sound if it sound is okay all right sorry guys I was
just in the bathroom I had to clean the bathroom guys sorry
don't worry I'm back at work don't worry I'm back though to
start my shift okay I had to make sure there's no motion
blur in my fucking convening game.
Alright, I'm here for my part-time job.
See, they say it was part-time and they say what time I had
to start.
I didn't think it was, I thought it was like English voice
acting.
You're in the bathroom for one night, this way you'll get my
case of Polaroids.
Golden, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Oh?
Hello?
Anki Panky Kamini, sir speaking.
How can I help you?
Makoto.
There you are.
I was starting to worry you.
answer.
I'm Hina, it's you.
Why are you still awake?
It's almost 5 a.m.
Oh honey, I just couldn't sleep.
It's your first shift alone after all.
How's your night going?
You shouldn't worry.
I've already placed some products on the shelves.
And now I'm taking a break to write in a notepad, just like
you told me to.
This sounds absolutely wonderful.
I can't wait to read about all your little escapees.
I forgot to tell you guys okay the next guest announcement
for the concert will be next week uh uh because uh we're
just finalizing some stuff right now so guest announcement
will be next week also because like there's a schedule for
the other guests for the other days on the other concert so
I was fine with moving my last guest announcement to all the
other guests for day one and two are announced so uh so the
next guest announcement is next week also we are planning
because of how fast the VIP ticket sold out.
I asked if we could add more VIP tickets.
So we're adding 50 more VIP tickets for the last guest
announcement.
If you already bought a general admissions ticket, do not
worry.
You can basically refund that.
If you get a VIP ticket, you can refund your general
admissions ticket from what I was told.
So you don't have, like you're like, oh no, I already spent
it on the general admission.
I want to get the VIP.
Do not worry.
If you grab a VIP ticket, you can refund your other ticket
as well so you won't lose any money all right i can't wait
to read all about your little escape escape it and escape
these i'm still not sure what i should put in there though
oh don't you worry just write from your heart remember
odyssey is tiki other employees also have notepads like
yours but mostly ask them to write down customer requests
that way they can always come back open the notepad and
check the notes maybe you could do that too I'll write down
things to do in my notepad as well.
Those notes might come in handy.
Day shift workers always leave their notepads lying around.
Take a look.
Maybe you'll find something interesting there.
By the way, since we're already speaking about the rascals,
those sloppy kids probably left a ton of mess in the store
again.
If you notice that the shelves are empty, or products are
placed inappropriately, please make sure to fix it.
As soon as you're done with everything, just flip the sign
on the door to let the customers know that you're open.
sign the front door to let customers in got it okay okay
sweetheart I won't take any more time I'm sure there's a lot
to do if you have any other questions on what you need to do
just call me I won't be asleep for another hour you'll find
my number on a business card next to the phone yeah I see
I'll write down everything you mentioned in my notepad so I
won't forget I'll call you if I need any extra help aunt
Hina bye break a lake sweetie bye bye I think I might need
to guys see see I knew I wasn't getting fired guys there's
no supervision they didn't know when I was gonna clock in
they let me go and he does not here let me go to the
bathroom real quick yeah I actually go grab cough drop so
I'll be right back i brought the i might have bone too hard
all right more bones god take my 45 minute break guys give
me a sec
all right i opened my notepad jesus christ okay i'm still
not sure what i should put in here but i guess i'll write
something somebody say that convening workers life is devoid
of any variety to tell you the truth I used to think it's so
too I spent summers visiting this store and never understood
why my auntie keeps working here back then never imagined
I'd be spending another win in this place and yet here I am
again all right place products from storage on shelves in
the sales area need help call on Alina's number two one zero
zero five one all right that seems fine oh my god the
sensitivity is fucking crazy okay give me that fucking max
five speed uh the fuck is the sensitivity jesus christ not
expecting that at first person control god it's still so
fast um good luck on your first shift alone dear please
bring out more soda i guarantee you tomorrow will be so hot
that will sell everything in time well i have to rely on my
aunt's instincts more she always know which goods will be in
demand No matter what day it is.
12 years of senior day shift, Clark.
No wonder she's meticulous about everything.
All right.
We'll grab that.
Then we'll grab more of that.
Then we'll keep grabbing that.
And then we'll grab that.
All right.
Here I go.
Oh, they're going to want beer, too.
Look at Maya.
Poshikawa.
They're going to want beer.
Oh, they're going to want hot sauce, too.
On a hot summer day?
What is that hot sauce?
What is that?
Is that also beer?
Oh, wait, it is beer.
All right.
On hot summer day, that's what's gonna sell.
But what about the bones?
Alright, let's go.
All drinks.
Can I run?
Yeah.
Don't put...
Tokyo pop.
And then we'll put some beer in here too.
Alright, beer next to the soda.
It's okay, it's 1983.
There's no laws yet.
It's okay.
There's no laws yet on not putting beer next to sodas.
We should be fine.
Huh?
Oh my god.
My bones.
They're so tight.
What else do I put the soda?
Wait.
Do I actually have to...
Are they forcing me to make sure I put all sodas?
No, they're not.
it doesn't matter.
All right, I'm taking that out then.
And then I'm taking this out too.
I'm putting my other beer.
Will anybody come in?
Hey, put.
Come in, we're open.
Hello?
Oh, I have to look outside.
Quite rains.
Weather tonight.
I don't think that going outside is a very good idea.
Oh, I could check got the capsule toy machine it's an old oh
my god it's your jokie master they're gonna oh my god is
that drag i think it's a dragon ball z parody but there are
no toys inside am i actually find some change maybe i should
try my luck tomorrow i should get back to work oh my god is
that gamma is that is that gamma right there Should I call
my aunt?
Why is no one coming to my store?
Where's the phone?
Where the fuck's the phone?
I don't call my aunt if I can't even find my phone.
The wild brother witnessed laughter, whispered conventions,
and the birth of lifelong friendship.
All filled by warmth and fire during those cold.
Oh, there's the phone.
Anjina!
I opened the store and no one's coming in you said it's
gonna be hot in summer I don't think you should be a wetter
lady on Hina you might I think you might have got the wetter
prediction wrong what do you want to know there are no
customers that miss something what should I do yeah there's
not many visitors at night so might take a minute or so
after a customer comes in they may require your help in that
case they'll usually ask you to come over then you have to
speak to them try to solve their issues try to be polite too
you didn't pay attention to the conversation don't hesitate
to interact with that customer again to clarify what they
want exactly do you have any other questions no i'm good
got it okay Is there anybody?
Did anybody come in while I was talking to my aunt?
Oh, oh!
There's a customer!
Hello, customer!
Welcome to the Campini!
Do we need help?
Good evening.
Welcome to our store.
Feel free to ask me if you need any help.
Good evening to you, young lady.
I will.
Thank you.
Hmm.
We're new here, aren't you?
Your face seems so familiar.
It's as if you weren't always worked here.
No, don't say that.
No, I don't...
I don't say that.
It's just part-time, right?
Right?
I'm not gonna work here forever, right?
Maybe it's because I look like my auntie.
You see, I'm helping my auntie here with a story.
Maybe that's why.
No, my future can't be convening.
I have...
Why am I gonna pay my college debt?
I just started working here today, but the new semester is
about to start.
So I'll be moving back home.
This is actually my only week at the store.
Convenie forever.
Oh, I see.
So you're helping your auntie.
Good of you.
Very good.
Wait a minute.
Does that mean your auntie is that old woman who runs this
place?
Yeah, that's her.
No future.
You can never leave.
What about my English liquor?
I'm sorry.
Surely I'll find a job with my English literature degree.
I spent a hundred grand on it for every week.
Now that's interesting.
You know, I've been coming here to get my groceries for
almost 10 years now.
And let me tell you, there are a few things in this world
that are as constant and reliable as a rising sun.
one of them.
However, we're not on the best of terms at this point, so
it's best that I stay out of her sight for now.
Quite a story that one is.
Quite a story.
Luckily, she only works during the day, so I have to sneak
into the store at night while she's not around.
Can you please not tell her that I came here?
What did you do?
Why not?
Is there a reason why?
Yeah, what did you do?
That would complicate things.
Let's leave it at that.
What's your name, by the way?
Makoto.
Nice to meet you, Makoto.
And I'm chief.
Everybody around here calls me chief.
Yeah, is she like my auntie's ex or something?
Nice to meet you, chief.
I better go grab all of the stuff, honey, and head up before
your auntie comes.
With diligence like her, she can march into the store to
check on you anytime.
I better be quick.
All right, where is she gonna get?
You want some beer?
I put beer in your basket for you, sir.
Look, we have specialty items.
We have pocky, the fungus, chocolate, and cat food.
What are you getting, sir?
Is he a murderer?
That's not sketchy.
Oh, why don't you want me to tell you about my auntie that
you were here?
I've never seen bread in the fridge before.
That's some... Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I heard that.
The reason why some...
it's like how like in europe people don't put their eggs in
the fridge doesn't that like doesn't that keep it fresh
though you put bread in the fridge what are you gonna get
because in europe people don't need to put their eggs in the
fridge because it's like there's no like chemicals in the
egg wait he went to the back oh i thought he went to the
bathroom can i go to the bathroom oh where our guests can
free up space for a second food serving.
What did he get?
Well, he got only Gary and some beer.
And then, I thought you gotta make it quick.
Why are you taking your time?
You should know what you're getting.
It's a convenience where a store is not that big.
Okay, what do you need help for?
Ah, yes, the sacred place for gaming.
I'm sorry, love.
Was there no Shirakdo deliveries today?
Oh, you mean shirako nidos?
I might have forgotten to put them on the shelf.
They can kindly wait just a moment and go to the back and
check.
I'm pretty sure we had them in stock.
That would be one.
You're full.
Naturally, wait.
Maybe it's a sign I was looking for.
A sign?
You're looking for a sign?
I don't know how to tell you this, but let's just say the
last few months have been quite rough for me.
Business is not doing good.
Then this thing with your auntie seems like i hit a string
of bad luck i'm so sorry about that it's all right anyway
i've been flipping through this week's horoscope and there
was this one line there follow the signs and your weather
will change i still don't quite know how to interpret this
oh no he's a hot he's a horoscope girlie weather probably
means that you're like hello hello i'm back i'm back
I told you, I told you.
You guys were like, Toki, you got to update your driver.
I told you every time.
Whoever the guy was like, was like flicking on my ass about
not updating drivers.
I told you.
This is why I don't update.
This is exactly why I don't update my drivers consistently.
Because every time, every time I update the drivers,
something happens to my pc
i fucking told you ever since i updated my all my stuff all
my games like keeps getting keeps crashing and like i would
have like full pc crashes too oh my god all right so
basically basically it was like a full it was like
everything like all my screens blacked out it was like like
full blacked out and then um like turned black and then um
and then after that it was like unity like overloaded or
something i don't know i didn't look at the error code i'm
sorry i should have looked at the error code but i was just
like i knew it i knew i was right i have a king i told you
so i can't i can say it dragons i told you so like yeah but
before the update it was just my game crashing but after i
updated my drivers everything was crashing so like um so
like not just my game but my obs and like all my programs
crashed as well so before i updated in pragmata before i
updated my drivers it was just it was just pragmata crashing
because i guess it was like the the drivers were not up to
date um but after i updated i don't know if you guys
remember after I updated my full all like stream shut down
to during the crash because this happened I was screen
sharing vampire crawlers to one of my friends it's like you
gotta play it you have to play vampire crawlers it's so fun
and then I had the black screen crash but my PC but because
I wasn't streaming it was just a black screen so while I was
like playing it and um and so like it has it has to do
something with with the drivers because uh because like it
only happened after i updated the drivers it's never
happened before so i need to downgrade my okay what is the
current best driver right now that's not the recent one my i
downloaded the one on april 28th because i did it on the
nvidia nvidia app because i was lazy uh i will downgrade it
right now
downgraded right now.
I forgot.
Do I have to install the old one?
Or do I just downgraded just from that?
Huh.
What is the current best one at the moment?
I need to install
the one I have is the 596.36.
So I don't know which one is the current current best driver
at the moment.
I'm on 595.
Okay, we'll try the 595 one.
595.79.
I might need to go to another bathroom break after
downgrading.
After that.
I'm so, I'm stressed now.
I need to use my bathroom break.
No joke, the best-in-of-it drive is 566.36 from December 20,
24, before AI code, go into drives, go out through all
formatted with other issues.
And you're in a super chat, Mexico.
Thank you.
All right, I'm at 5.9, okay, 5.96.36.
okay i'm on five okay everyone's on different fives now
everyone's on all right do we do all right we have 595.96
596.36 okay which one okay it's like a little gamble right
now uh i guess we'll never know what he wanted 420.69 i
think that might be in a 1080 graphics card die try one okay
five that's from that's like older than the one i had
originally because originally mine was like 2025 for july uh
let's see uh but mecto think of the super chat thingy thingy
yeah uh we'll do five i see more 595.97 okay do i have to i
forgot because it's been a while since I've downgraded
drivers.
Last time I downgraded, it was for Marvel Rivals because,
like I said, I downloaded a driver and then it kept crashing
when I played Marvel Rivals, so I had to downgrade.
But when I downgrade, do I need to uninstall the old drivers
or can I just downgrade through that driver?
Because I don't know.
Oh my God, I don't even remember.
There were so many choices to pick from.
That's right.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I got roasted for not updating my drivers.
Now look where I am.
And now look at this.
I see all of you guys haven't updated your drivers too.
Oh, now you guys exposed yourself.
I see all those 5-9-1s and 5-9-4s.
That's the right.
Calling me out when you guys also did update your drivers.
We got one guide.
It's gonna miss you on your part.
Alright.
God damn hypocrites.
You, why don't you My driver right now, 596.36.
Come on, come with me.
All right, you chicken.
You cowards.
Of course I did.
I'm not crazy.
I already forgot which one I wanted to update, too.
Oh, downgrade, too.
Someone said I'm just going to trade.
try the 595.79 I'm on 595.
A lot of people are sitting there on 595.
I did 595.97 or 595.7.
I'll do 595.97.
I don't know.
There's so many 5.9s.
I don't know which 5.9 is to pick from.
5.97
I'll do 5.95.97 or 0.79.
Oh my god, there's so many numbers.
I can't pick.
There's so many 0.5s and 7s and 6s.
I've been using the latest drivers and never had problems.
We do more models or more CPU heads.
So you may need a bigger CPU.
They gave us Super Chat.
Yeah, but I had no problems before.
I had no problems before until update that's the issue like
it was fine it was only like pragmata was just crashing so I
updated the driver and everything was fine after that but
then like after that um everything just crashes because I
never had actual crashes for in a long time so it had to be
something to do with it had to be like the update um that's
it 595 NVIDIA download I'm just downloading it I'm
graduating I know you say congratulations to jesse of course
i trap thank you for super chat thank you thank
congratulations on graduating jesse i'm really proud of you
oh you have a nice one relaxing time before you go into the
job market um trap thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you also my cpu is like super uh a buff too it's it's
super oh what's the word i know it was expensive a tech word
for it for it being buff as hell uh uh let's see all right
i'm downloading 595 point yeah it's super beefy there we go
i'm downloading it right now i'm just gonna go straight to
595.79 and then we're gonna go back to having our bathroom
break cool down
the convene stream is our little our little guinea pig
before our pi mouse stream because i don't want to crash on
that one it's very annoying it's definitely very annoying
though because i don't mind if it's just a game crash like
pragmata when it was just a game crashing but like the whole
everything shutting down is so annoying because that's what
happened right like it was just a game crashing and then
like and then after that i updated and then that everything
decided to go wrong.
All right.
Updating, downgrading right now to 595.79.
Agree and continue.
Express.
What was the driver before?
It was the driver before it was July 2025.
That's where it was.
I'm pretty sure.
All right.
I'm stalling the new drivers.
Yeah, everything changed when the updates are attacked.
for shout thank you thank you hey dokey just got back from
the hospital it really helped my recovery to have you hear
you say robin wizard should definitely get that sexy dokey
lower back tattoo look i'm not gonna and i'm not gonna say
say that you should but you have your own free will papa
smurf if in 40 years you look back at that tattoo and you're
like nice then then you Maybe it'd be a great idea.
But if in 40 years you're like, Donkey Bird, why did you
tell me to get this set?
That's not on me.
That is not on me.
Donkey trap, step.
Look, if you think that your future girlfriend and wife will
be okay with that.
Wait, maybe.
If you marry or date a dragon, definitely be okay with that
wait nvidia installer failed and you were you were a same
version okay so i do have to uninstall it okay um how do i
downgrade again i'm trying to remember it's been so long
since i downgrade a driver how do i downgrade a driver oh my
god it's been way too long how to downgrade it it won't let
me clean and like just straight up install it okay click
start click control panel the control panel it's time to
google this i'm at the nvidia help driver roll back right
now uh click performance and maintenance this is the tech
support stream
all right performance all right performance and maintenance
oh that's security and maintenance maintenance.
Oh, Windows XP steps to roll back.
Okay, never mind.
Windows.
Why is it Windows XP?
Okay, start control panel.
Click systems.
Why the fuck is it on Windows?
Why is the NVIDIA instruction sheet on Windows XP?
Who is still using Windows XP?
Who has the privilege of still
grid or some shit how do they still have windows xp now xp
lives on like god i would like how did how did they not
force him to keep on using it hey device manager there we go
all right device manager okay Double click on display
adapters.
And if it select click on roll back, there's no roll back.
Where the fuck did they get roll back?
Did they have that option in the power?
There you go.
Uninstall.
Okay.
Uninstall disabled device.
If your device fails, roll back to previously.
I can't even roll it back.
It doesn't even give me the fucking privilege.
It really is like, nuh-uh, no, no, no.
Okay, roll back.
I don't remember how to do it, guys.
I need to Google this.
It's been so long.
You cannot use this method.
Okay.
Download display drivers uninstaller.
Guys, do I download display driver uninstaller?
Or is it going to...
Or is it going to farm my Bitcoin?
Or is it going to turn my PC into a Bitcoin farmer?
Have you tried admin privileges?
I don't, I mean, I could try.
Have you tried?
I mean, I could try.
It's good.
I use it.
All right, let's see.
Yeah, I can't, even on admin mode, it doesn't let me.
I double-checked on admin mode.
I manually download a driver, but it says I have to
uninstall another driver, like uninstall the other driver,
because they're like, oh, you're already using a recent
driver, so we can't do it.
And I'm like, what do you mean you can't do it?
Like, what do you mean?
I know I've done it before.
I haven't done it on this PC before.
That's why I don't have the program.
I know I used them.
I think I did use a pro.
Oh, I do have it.
I literally have it right here.
I have the EXE file right here for.
the display driver uninstaller updates are available no
expanded limit support all right that's fine no i don't need
a no it's fine i have i actually do have it that you're not
using i i know i'm not using the latest one it's okay i just
clean and do not may cause issues like black that's fine
i just want you to uninstall it try to try to create a
system restore port All right, we're going to do a clean and
do not.
We're going to risk it all.
It's okay.
We're going to do a clean and do not restart.
What could go wrong?
Live on stream.
I just highly recommend that you clean and restart.
You're careful now.
This is a, is this going to be a guide on what not to do
very soon?
I could be one way or another.
All right.
Is it doing it?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if it's doing it or not.
Let's go gambling, guys.
Surely everything will be.
Hello?
Hello.
I am back.
I don't think I got all my settings, but Like, I got
everything I needed to do.
I got my 500 hertz.
And then my vertical monitor is no longer vertical.
So it is vertical again.
And I think that is good enough, honestly.
I don't know what Heather's settings.
I don't remember my gamer settings.
So that is a little bit concerning.
Because if you play video games, you know you have to
customize some specific stuff uh so that you can have
everything running properly uh man this is awesome i think
you deserve a two-hour vampire crawler the app break after
this turkey thank you super chat thank you thank you so i
might have to ask one of my friends for like their gamer
settings so i can optimize like frames frames and stuff
all right maybe let me double check everything real quick uh
okay display i gotta see if the resolution is at the correct
okay yeah 60 hertz on the other monitors and that's fine
uh because you're supposed to edit the manage 3d settings to
make it so okay
max frame rate
oh whatever i'll have one of my friends help out later oh
this okay wow this was so exhausting i guess i gotta take my
second lunch break real quick
wow the only way that can fix my stress i guess i gotta take
my second lunch break
what oh boy don't worry don't worry they'll understand it's
five in the morning apparently and in convene so they'll
understand all right let's go grab what should we grab let's
go grab oh i can afford it now let's add more mana so i can
throw more bones all right well deserved yeah very well
deserved lunch break do i need to have more oh there's
There's more.
There's more at the dairy plant.
Oh boy!
More bones!
To that one guy on the Twitter that was like, I'm so happy
you're doing variety, you're playing more variety games.
I'm sorry.
Welcome to more bones.
We're back at it again with bones.
Alright, let me know the stuff.
is okay I don't know if my sound stuff also got reset so
we're just gonna do it live this is variety what do you mean
I have an early crown which is good
fire a little bit fire with my bones oh no they got him they
got the convene a convene he's with bones!
Yeah, this is from the creators of vampire survivors.
They know how to make a good ass game.
That's all I'm gonna say.
This is technically still variety.
That's what we tellers.
That's how we go.
Everything's technically...
It's on a technicality right now.
Keep on throwing the bone, mad fucking love Inconveni, guys.
What a great game.
What a great game, guys.
I can't believe their bathroom breaks are so immersive.
That's definitely what I do in the bathroom.
Can't believe they have an option to play vampire crawlers
in the Inconveni bathroom.
He played Inconveni for, like, three hours.
hours you deserve.
You're so right.
So true.
Retain.
Oh my god.
That means I can.
Oh wait, no.
Earn coins when...
Alright, I can add armor to my bones.
I'm always chucking them out anyway.
I need that XP and X2 tome!
I can throw more bones out.
Okay, I do need the armor though.
I know that kills them.
Okay, it kills one of them.
It's okay.
I have so much armor.
Okay, I have one armor.
This is our stress test, okay?
We're testing out the PC.
We're stress testing it right now.
Okay, we can get more XP, though.
Oh my god, that one guy.
Don't worry, I know what to do.
Just throw that one bone in there.
Okay.
Ooh.
If I draw, I can draw more bones.
Yeah.
Okay, I gotta save one of the bones for either XP or X2
though.
There is a chance I can draw another bone.
Whoops.
Oh, there he goes.
See, I told you!
I told you!
We can draw another bone!
Okay.
Bye.
Stress text, Apex.
Don't worry, I'm playing this on 500 frames.
I'm pretty sure.
Where's the graphics?
Look at that.
500 hertz.
Wait, why do I have motion blur on my bone game?
What am I blurring out?
It's all pixels.
Like, what the fuck am I blurring out?
The bone, Stokie.
It's...
Peak frames.
I gotta be able to see every bone.
The guy will never...
The guy is like...
Where is my...
Where is the convene worker?
She said she was gonna help us.
Don't want to be right there with you, sir.
The bath...
I just gotta clean the bathroom right now.
I'll be right with you, sir.
Any moment now.
Alright, let's get the cross.
Cross is strong.
Sorry, my aunt called me and told me to check on the
bathroom real quick.
I'll be right with you very soon.
There's someone's leaving so many bones in the bathroom.
I had to go check it out.
Nice.
Grab that.
We got to sweep that off all the bones.
Bone.
All right, let's see.
I don't think I can upgrade anything here.
Yeah.
Oh, we'll grab a spinach bucket.
Yeah, who put all these bones in here?
All right, anyway, what else do I have to worry about with
everything resetting itself?
I'm not too, I'm a little worried about it.
Just a little bit.
What are shaders?
Oh, I mean, shaders is just putting up the game, right?
And then they just compile.
Do you mean like shaders as in like compiling shaders?
Or like, like something specific to that.
I get braced so I can grab more cards in my hand.
Or gold armor?
I think Brace is better.
Oh, it's just combined.
Okay, I don't have to worry about that too much.
I just gotta wait.
That's just a waiting game.
Honestly.
I can wait.
Not too bad.
Oh my god, bow!
Okay, nice.
We need that.
We need more bones in this game.
Shit.
Wait, it's just all...
junk and then let's
get rid of all the junk first oh my god now I'm so confused
okay that in that then that and then we draw a card and then
that and then this and then we do that and then we do that
and then we bone and then catalyst to set the mood.
Draw a card.
Magic.
Uh, you want more XP.
Chuck more bones into the problem.
Boning by the cannibalite.
Ooh.
Let's evolve.
Make that fire one into us.
Hellfire wand!
Fuck it, just dip that wand into the depths of hell.
Okay, bone, bone.
Two.
More magic and then more bones.
Yay!
And then, bone!
Bone, bone!
Bone, bone, bone.
Candle.
Cross.
Uh.
More crown.
More XP.
I demand more!
Okay, I might need more ones, though.
I'm running out of ones.
Okay, that should have my crown.
There it is.
Zero.
Oh.
Never mind.
Just zero.
Yeah, I'm just on my second lunch break right now.
Add a wild card.
Trigger abilities for free at the start.
Move crawlers.
Add a wild card each floor.
Alright, I'll do it.
I'll do that.
That has more projectiles for me.
Which means I can fire more bones.
Which is always a good side.
What's that?
More bones.
Yes.
Don't worry.
I'm going to get that XP tome any minute now.
Any minute that XP tome is going to show up.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
If I put it on the bone, it stays in hand until used.
Manicast is increased by...
Oh my god.
Like, I just imagined I put that on.
Actually, no.
No, I shouldn't put that on anything.
Okay, I could put that on the light tome.
And then everything will be zero.
Wait, I could put that on the weighty tome.
And that could be one.
Okay.
Bone.
Cross.
Crown.
Okay, it's fine.
I didn't press crown, though.
You even put...
Oh, it can be minus one.
And then it gives me mana if I use it.
I assume that's what it is.
That's just an insubption.
I don't actually know what it does.
Because like when they do the confused card, it has minus
one on my card.
It just refunds me.
Oh, I should have used a weighty tome.
I was too mad with power with bones.
All I could think about was the bones.
I'm just going mad with absolute power.
Guys, I'm just stress testing the game right now.
We'll go back to Kambini very soon.
There's one last bone for the ride.
It's one last one.
One last run.
We're just making sure that it's working, you know?
making sure that the game isn't gonna crash ancient home
santa I feel like we need more threes we'll grab santa water
okay oh magic cross yeah I'm testing my settings okay
fire and then
Ooh, we'll get three, too.
We need a three anyway.
Oh, that's not what I wanted, but that's fine.
We'll go with that.
And then armor.
Alright, get that lamp out of here.
Okay, bone.
Oh, we need more one.
Wait, do we need more ones now?
Can't tell.
I've lost cat.
remember our bones.
No, we have ones.
We might need twos?
I think we need twos.
Let's banish this.
We don't need the heart.
Just throw the water in here.
Light Tome.
Take that.
Armor.
Chandelier.
Get that chunk out of here.
And then Oh my god, whoops!
Chuck that extra bone in here, everything, I've lost count.
Oh nice.
Chuck two more bones in here too.
Yay, $500, let's go!
We did it!
So easy.
Oh my god, yes.
Yes!
Okay, we'll put it across.
Across is actually super OP with the X2.
Maximum.
Look at all the money.
I'm so rich.
Where's the next cemetery?
I gotta make a trip to the cemetery.
No relation whatsoever what I'm doing.
We did it!
Okay, let's get the combo.
I think we might need another armor just in case though.
Oh, never mind.
We might need to span our inventory.
Double damage, that means more damage.
Oh my god, you know what that means.
Double the money.
Double the bones.
Okay, yeah, 2x on cross is actually so strong.
Alright.
Shuck it all!
Take it all!
Yes!
Okay, we might need...
I don't even know what numbers we need anymore.
I've actually...
100% last gap.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
Guys, what number am I missing?
I don't know.
I don't know what numbers we're missing.
We couldn't put that on.
Oh my god, we could put it on a bone.
We could put it on the bone.
Twos?
Are you missing twos or ones?
Oh my god, just imagine.
I'm going to put it on the bone.
That'd be like minus one, zero, one, and then bone to bone
combo.
Just for fun.
Okay, we're zero.
Two.
Three.
And then...
Oh my god.
Oh, you're dead already anyway.
I was like, oh my god, I can restart the combo.
The possibilities are endless.
A bone-up bone action.
Just thinking about it.
We'll put two in there.
I actually don't know what number we're missing.
I think ones and threes.
Ones and threes.
Okay, minus one.
And then we go into a zero.
And then we do that.
And then we draw another card.
And then they're all dead.
dead.
What is Charles play?
Send me a real challenge!
Say it's in hand until used.
I can only use that.
I'll just put it on the cross just for fun.
Okay, now we need ones and twos.
Alright, we got extra one.
Okay, we're missing a lot of twos now.
We are...
Okay, we gotta grab this.
Oh, never mind.
That's a re...
What?
Oh, okay, he's blocking the other thing.
What can I get rid of?
I have nothing to get rid of, guys.
Absolutely nothing.
Okay, I can get rid of a map.
Oh my god.
I have, like, nothing in my inventory to get rid of.
rid of these things okay wait bone yes yes this
is not the advertisement don't we're just stressed we're
just in the bathroom break right now you know don't worry
we'll come back to the game very soon we're just in a
bathroom break oh my god four yes we can finally count up to
four now We're just making sure everything works.
We had a little technical issue.
Oh, oh, you're still alive?
You lived to turn number two?
I'm not letting, I'm not making sure this never happens
again.
The eternal bathroom break.
Two.
Okay, we need threes now.
Alright, remember threes!
Yes!
Exactly what I needed, a streamer buff!
The streamer buff is here!
We gotta grab that, we gotta grab the chicken.
It's not like we really need it or anything.
At that point, it's just a flex.
Oh, there's the boss.
Maybe you should have recruited more people to your army,
bro.
That's right, I'm here.
Knock, knock.
Hurried somebody's special day.
Hurried somebody's birthday.
Alright, nice.
Oh, back, we're at the eyes already?
Oh, so easy.
There we go.
Get out of here!
We need like twos and threes.
I'll grab another two for the money.
And then grab this.
Give me that attractor.
Oh!
No!
I don't need that upgrade.
all I need the attractor I took down I don't need it who
needs that when I have bone I don't regret anything at all
no everything's fine
Okay, Skana, Light Tomb, Tractor Orb.
I think it's going well though so far.
I think the PCs are right now with the downgrade.
Oh my god, that was an infinite combo.
No, no, no.
I made sure to say please don't steal anything from the
store.
We are a small business owner.
And I think we'll be fine.
Do not worry.
I think we'll be okay.
There's no way they'll steal from me.
It was 1980s.
There's no way.
We need threes.
I don't put a three.
I feel like we need twos, but I'm just going to put a three
just in case.
We'll continue the combo.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
With no security cameras or anything back then.
Who would steal from the store?
It would be so fine.
Alright, the nuke is here.
Alright, uh...
We'll draw a card.
Get a tome.
Get the chandelier.
Get hellfire.
Yeah, that's illegal.
Stealing is illegal.
I'll grab more friendship amulet.
The friendship amulet is coming in clutch.
Or the bullshit combos I'm trying to make right now.
Give me your money.
See, that won't happen at my store that I'm taking a
bathroom break right now for.
Don't worry.
That won't happen there.
That's different.
Pirates 10 more projectiles.
I like the sound of that.
Why skip the machine?
I know I don't need the passives.
I don't need it.
That's how confident I am.
Oh my god.
I need twos, man.
Stop giving me ones.
Okay, I'll just grab this.
I'm going to grab a zero then the ones and two so then it
can be like a black slate.
I'll reset it.
And then I'll do that.
And I'm going to reset it.
And I'm going to reset it again.
And I get 10%.
Zero.
One.
Bone.
Yeah, that's why I picked the spell binder.
Oh.
Alright, goodbye, chicken.
Zero.
One.
Continue, 0, 1.
Continue.
Time 7 combo.
Okay, we'll pick up a card.
We'll grab armor.
We'll grab the cross.
And then we end the combo.
Okay, we need a twos, right?
Twos, yeah.
I sort of lost count already.
I assume we needed a two.
Because I've been seeing a lot of zeros and ones.
Minus one.
Zero.
One.
Two.
All right, we need twos.
We just need twos.
What was over here?
Wait, did I not pick up a card?
Oh, I didn't pick up the card.
What is that?
Oh, limit breaks over a kill.
Oh, we need that.
Now we can have all the money in the world.
Oh, I did not mean to do that.
Whoops.
It's alright, we killed everything though.
That heard about the bone situation.
Bing yang, axe, empty tome, axe!
Alright, now we have all the numbers we need.
And then we draw another card.
Then we continue.
And then...
Okay.
Draw another card.
1, 2, and then we draw another card.
0, 1, and then we bone.
And then spinach, and then scatter.
Oh no.
What do all these numbers mean?
Oh!
I'll just take my mana, too.
What do these numbers mean?
one two and then water oh man I wish I could kill more the
numbers they're trying to tell me something that's a
confused card confused dokey oh oh the death site I know the
death site's really good all right we'll grab the death I
have like 600 I need more kills more death I won't be
satisfied more
more oh actually I went three and four I want to prolong it
even more I want to see their faces when I bone them with
the bones there
we go do we need more I'll Grab more grace.
One more cards in my head.
My God, these guys are strong.
Cross.
I'm at the restart here.
One.
Two.
Three.
Combo.
And then luck.
I'll see a light leave their eyes.
I don't want to kill them too fast.
I enjoy the most.
Savor the moment.
Oh my god, dad.
One.
Two.
Zero.
A one.
Okay, that's a one.
I miscounted.
There's so many.
I have so many cards.
Okay.
Zero.
One.
There we go.
I might need more mana.
Oh, speak.
Oh, times two.
Oh, I might need more mana tomes.
Oh, oh, guess not.
Guess I don't.
You need more damage.
Pick up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I guess I actually meant more damage.
Okay, grab the reroll.
I'll be right with you, sir.
Oh my god.
Gosh, this bathroom is so dirty.
I'm still cleaning the bathroom, so I'll be right with you
very soon
So I'm the only employee today
All right, let's see Yeah, tome tome Deaf site
Friendship, armor, tome, back here, and then bam.
Oh, wait, you're still alive.
Minus 1, 0, 1, 2, 3, and then I end the combo here.
And then grab it, and then water.
Oh, well, that's...
Oh, pep!
Pentagram, oh my god, pentagram is so strong.
I definitely need more mana tomes, though.
I really need more mana tomes.
Unless I get mega bird.
Oh my god, wait, wait, okay.
Alright, wait, I have to look at that.
I can't have him barked too long.
Alright, I'm back.
Alright.
He already ate.
He already, he's not hungry.
three hours ago mega bird fucking no I had times to no I
forgot I forgot I had times to I got so excited above mega
bird mega bird was so exciting I say
I kept thinking about mega birds.
He was so mega.
Oh my god.
I know crown plus pentagram can evolve.
So I'll grab the crown just in case.
No, no, I'll come back.
I'll come back to Kampini very soon.
Just one more run.
I'm still on run number two right now.
Calcio.
Don't worry Do
I have enough?
Two, three.
Am I just running this and then this?
If the milk is going bad, just put it back in the fridge and
I'll help you later.
I'll be back later soon, very soon.
Okay, I know...
I know I... Okay.
I could combine the... Okay.
All right, I'm gonna say I'm gonna restrain.
I'm gonna practice restraint right now
Zero one.
Oh fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
I could put three and I can go back And I can go back and
bone
All right zero one
One No, he's finished off.
There we go.
And then...
Minus 1, 0...
Minus 1, 2, 0, 1, finish pentagram.
What do I need anymore?
Like, tomes?
I guess not tomes.
Toomes?
Ah, fuck it.
There's more fight.
More damage.
I don't know what I need anymore.
I feel like I have everything I want.
This finish.
And then...
There we go.
Go back to where you need to earn money.
You need to go to your nine to five.
Don't worry, I'll be right with you, sir.
Very soon.
Just give me five more minutes.
I can help you check out.
Threes, right?
Threes.
Or mana.
Okay, we might actually need more mana, though.
Zero.
One.
two three five get
the money they're gonna embrace which is good that means we
can have more cop more bones in our deck oh my god we're
just it's just everywhere
Okay.
One.
Two.
Three.
We need a four.
We need a four for the pentagram.
I zero one, two.
Okay.
I think this will wipe everything.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
It doesn't matter if I do a bigger combo.
It would just wipe it all up.
Oh, nope.
No need for the chicken, sir.
I'm mega full right now.
And one, zero, one, two, three, zero.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, fuck, they touched me.
Who let that happen?
Oh, my God, there's so many cards.
What do are any of these cards?
What's in my hand right now?
I can't see anything.
I actually can't even see anything.
okay all right um uh i can't even see anything in my hand
right now
okay put armor um okay just in case any something happens
oh my god what am i holding what am i holding what what's in
my my pocket.
I'm 792.
Wait, Pentagram.
I might have.
There might be a possibility that I might have too many
cards.
Just maybe.
I'm not sure yet, though.
As I put another card in my deck.
It's just a theory that I'm They have accidentally got too
many cards.
Just maybe.
The game theory.
Oh god.
I don't even see cards anymore.
Uh...
Two!
You know what?
Fuck that one bird.
Let's go.
Big Bird versus Big Bird.
Turn minus what?
No, I don't have a minus what.
All right, this.
This.
Bone.
Cross.
Friendship Amulet.
Death from above.
Zero, one.
And then more death.
Zero.
One.
Two.
Three.
We continue on.
on and then combo.
Oh god.
15 cards.
Okay.
1.
0.
Light tome.
Oh my god.
What's in my fucking hand right now?
2000.
2.
3.
What's in my hand?
Oh my god.
0.
One!
Counting Wodoki?
Okay, done.
So many.
Oh.
Don't worry, we'll come back.
We'll come back to Conveni.
We don't need to change the title, guys.
We'll be back, guys.
Do not worry.
We're counting Wodoki right now.
We're learning how to count.
Minus one...
Zero...
One...
Two...
Three...
Zero.
The stream starts at two hour mark.
We're almost there!
We're almost- This is the last one!
This is the last boss, guys!
Right here!
Last boss!
Yes!
Eh.
all right i end my turn oh my god i'm here here and then oh
fuck okay not here not here okay see that's the last guy
that's the last guy guys we're almost there
okay continue
all right i can look at 10 cards Wait, he hurt me.
Wait.
That's not part of the plan.
Wait a minute.
How did he hurt me?
Oh, it's okay.
He's dead.
Alright, never mind.
Nothing to worry about.
I don't see.
How is that possible?
Wait, that's not allowed.
I'm not supposed to bleed.
Oh, there we go.
This is what I wanted to do.
I kept that crown for so long for this one moment I'm dead
anyway.
There we go guys.
All right All right, sir, the bathroom's clean now.
No need to thank me
Easy I don't just upgrade all of that.
I don't even know what to upgrade next honestly I've just
been all in on the fucking heart skip choices and get xp2
per rank increase luck maybe luck earn 25% more coins attack
splash add an armor there's an armor when it hurt oh oh oh
that's what they mean by an extra crawler slide oh my biffin
this wrong?
Wait.
Have I been playing this game?
Have I just been soloing it the entire... Have I been
supposed to bring two people in?
Wait a minute.
You mean I could have two?
I can have bones and someone else?
Oops.
Oh, that's awkward.
Well then.
I'm still all in on the bone guy Double down on bones I must
solo this Alright Back to the convening now Alright I think
the guy has been waiting for me Look I could solo this And I
was right I can solo this Alright Back to the convening
store.
Alright.
Alright, sorry.
I had to clean the bathroom back now.
Yeah, sure.
Alright, okay.
We gotta get him his noodles.
Alright, we gotta remember to ask him about his sign.
What's interesting about the loot store is that it is
actually made by another facility based on Shanghai.
So it really feels premium.
Hmm.
You know what?
You decide.
From this point on, I'm open to anything new.
What would you recommend?
Well, let me think.
You know what?
Ramen Express Luxie.
You should really try.
It's a bit on the expensive side, but it melts your mouth,
and it's absolutely delicious!
I should definitely try this one.
The way you describe makes me want to go home and eat it
right away.
Thanks for the suggestion.
I'd complain, but if I worked in a convene, I'd be playing
Vampire Crawley.
in the bathroom as well.
I wish she would run.
I should just leisurely walking.
Which one is Ramen Express Hot and Spicy?
Let's go.
Alright, here you go.
I got one Ramen Express right here.
Oh, wait.
How do I give it to him?
That's I just can't, you see, my cat Mimi is acting weird.
It's like she avoids me and doesn't want to cuddle anymore.
Oh, she already got it.
I was just recommending it to him.
That's why I ventured to the store in this weather.
To bring my princess a premium treat.
Maybe she just needs some love, you know?
Someone suggested I try this special hyperallergenic cat
food.
I was hoping to find it here, but the names are so
unbelievably small.
I can't see a thing.
Will you please find a can for me?
The one I'm looking for should have a green pea formula or
something.
Do you have anything like that?
Let me take a look.
Alright.
Green pea...
That's for dogs.
Cat food with special...
Catfutuna.
Premium cat gourmet.
Cat bites.
Who the fuck is the hyperallergenic cat food?
Premium cat gourmet.
Low calorie.
That was That guy was a child At first He came into the
store Fifty years ago Looking for soda
Really?
Where is this cow food?
From the box Oh, okay, I was gonna Wait, what?
I can't escape Oh, and Oh, I have to inspect it Okay, it has
to be one of the gourmet Shit all right inspect a big bag of
high quality okay not that offers all luxurious not that is
it tuna cute cats growth no it's just tuna cat oh there you
go green pea formula there it is oh oh well i need to put
one away all right i got it i got cat food in the ramen
okay here you go here you go is this the one you're looking
for oh my oh my thanks for the help i still can't see the
name on the cat but i'll trust you anyway my pleasure it's
nice of you to take such a good care of your cat i hope she
likes the food well i guess we'll see i hope this one will
make her feel better okay now i can cross food cat food on
my list Okay, make sure I didn't forget anything.
Soda, cat food.
What else did I need?
Wait, didn't you want my ramen?
Oh, wait, here you got it.
Ramen.
Alright, let's put this box away.
I put my box away.
Oh, there you go.
Put this box.
There you go.
Don't worry, sir.
I'm gonna help you.
I'm ready to clock in my first day of work.
Let me scan them for you.
Got my cashier key.
Uh.
Oh.
Beep.
There we go.
I'll scan.
That'll be a thousand two one 110 let's see so he gave me a
thousand and 250 okay i'll just put that amount in the
machine and then oh no oh it's all in yen no no it's all in
coins i hope here you go i hope everything is to your
satisfaction there you go my first customer thank you for
your purchase please come again I should thank you, Deary.
You've been a great help tonight.
This is the only place where I can go to get groceries.
So I'll definitely come back.
This you can count on.
I see you're taking good care of the store except for this
one bread in the refrigerator.
I'm so sorry about that.
I was supposed to put it somewhere else.
That's okay.
It made me chuckle anyway.
Just make sure you always have cat food.
My princess deserves only the best cuisine.
Got it.
I'll make sure that we have this item in stock at all times.
Is anything alright?
Yeah, it's fine.
Just a bit worried, that's all.
Did I do something wrong?
No, that's not it.
You've been a great help tonight.
I guess I feel that I finally ran out of luck.
I feel like there's this huge shadow over my head, but my
business and everything.
Even my own cat doesn't like me anymore.
Yesterday's horoscope said that if I follow the signs, my
mother would change, and yet everything is still the same.
sometimes I look at the sky desperate to find a sign there
like some kind of province that would tell me chief the dark
times are over it's gonna be all right have you ever
considered therapy I'm so sorry Makoto do you believe I will
find my sign tell them the truth oh I tell them chief I I
really don't know I love to tell you that you Well, my
story, this is a convenie.
Have you ever considered therapy?
But, Riley, I just don't know.
I'll be honest, I'm a little worried today, too, about being
alone in the story for the first time.
Oh, my God, he got closer.
What do you want?
Oh, he actually got out of his bed for once.
He actually moved instead of barking from his fucking bed.
What?
He's kind of hot.
Sorry, he's like, I got up because I wanted to pick him up.
At least he could, like, sit on my lap while instead of
barking.
And then he ran into his little fucking doghouse.
But about me returning to college in a week, not even
knowing who I want.
I don't even know what he was.
I think he just, it's like the thrill for him.
It's like the thrill of the chase.
This guy really just reenacted the drive-through
trauma-dumping meme.
one dead guy thinking the super chat thinking thank you he
he heard all about all the bones and he's like where is it
where are the bones that i've been promised of anywhere all
the time that's what you do you look but don't see we're
here but don't listen that's what my auntie always used to
say so yes maybe you won't find your sign here today chief
but maybe just maybe you already did And you just didn't
notice.
You truly are, Hina's niece, after all.
Giving wise advice must run in your family.
You're right.
I've been worrying too much.
Enough being depressed.
I'll let go and not dwell on it anymore.
That's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to come home, feed my cat, and enjoy the evening.
Maybe even cracked open that new box of noodles that you've
recommended.
Thank you for being honest.
It means a lot to me.
in the store today, by the way.
You're a very good kid, Makoto.
Your auntie should be very proud of you.
I'll be seeing you again, dear.
Good night, Chief.
Hope to see you soon.
Yay!
Another customer satisfied.
We did it, guys.
Why is he just standing there?
Yeah.
Are you okay?
I'm sorry.
do you need anything else anything else well you're standing
in the door I thought maybe you forgot something oh no
dearie thank you you've helped me enough for today I'm
actually waiting for something come take a look at the sky
with me can you see see what that crimson glow on the
horizon with the color of a ripe apple to me it looks like
the color of a discount coupon for pastry that you get after
8 p.m.
or that color on the box of spicy noodles makoto dot dot dot
you know i just remembered something in addition to the
color crimson symbolizing aleness and welfare can also be a
sign of good weather to come it's that's right the rain has
oh my god which which how did he do How did he do it?
How did he do it?
It stopped raining.
.
Oh my god, stay too already?
What a great day at work.
We had one customer.
.
We're one and done.
We made so much progress on day one.
One very happy customer.
I'm surprised my aunt can afford a second one, a part-time
worker.
That's a community maybe.
won't survive one customer at six in the morning what a
great day
yay we beat the game it looks like an ending credit yay we
beat the game guys we did it
Achievement Unlocked.
Welcome to the store.
It only took two hours.
Alright, Tuesday.
Thanks for the game, Doki.
Alright, Tuesday, August 24th, 1993.
The summer he is relentless, and today was no exception.
This store, if you're not going to buy it, feels like an
oven.
I'm drenched in sweat.
I wonder if Auntie Ever gets tired of this.
What's my second night here, and I'm still not sure what I'm
here for.
But I can't let you hurt down.
They obviously see something special in this place.
Who knows?
Perhaps today it could give me some new insight.
I just hope I don't melt before the shift ends.
Hmm.
Looks like a day shift worker left some sticky notes with
tasks.
If only I can read Japanese.
Let's take a look.
If only she wrote it in English.
Thank you for working so hard on the first night shift.
Toshinoru and I really appreciate it.
We're so sorry we couldn't meet you in person before.
She has three other...
My aunt hired three other part-timers.
We had one customer yesterday.
It would have been nice to properly introduce ourselves.
Things go, it would be a little hectic.
And we accidentally ordered way too much ice cream.
We had to stash it in every free shirt could fly.
If anything stands out of place, it's probably our fault.
Found this golden ring near the sink.
Not sure who it is.
So I'm keeping it in my pocket for now.
Tina called today and asked about you.
Of course, I told her how well you did on your first shift.
Guys, see, I did really well.
oh yeah three part-timers is less than one full-time and
that is true we can pay all of them three dollars an hour
and then have them rely on tips i told her how well you did
on your first ship but she would probably glad to hear your
impressions in person she warned me that she slept during
the day so you can safely call her anytime that you want to
chat and ask your questions okay i gotta run lots of work
today that is true you know three dollars might be a bit too
much maybe $1 an hour, and then everything else is relying
on tips.
Alright, oh, we got some pastries.
Oh, we got some manga down here.
We got some shonen jump.
Alright, we are open.
I don't think I need to put anything away.
What's in the freezer?
Ooh.
Alright, we're open.
Oh my god, there's like a little baby sink.
Oh, that's cute.
Anyway, it's time to go on my bathroom.
Time to go to another bed.
No customers?
I think it's time.
There's no customers, guys.
What can I do?
Why is the sink is used for?
It's placed so loud.
There's a bend down.
You want to wash your hands here?
Yeah, it's a baby sink.
Then you want to come over?
Hello?
Hang on.
customer have a little snack while enjoying a wonderful
scenic view mysterious thief appears residents of local
towns are buzzing after the latest appearance of the
mysterious thief this modern modern day enigma stuck struck
again this morning running away with food and essential
products despite his fevery witnesses are reported seeing
him help strand animals and perform other acts of kindness
oh it's just some guy that's homeless he's just getting
essential items just a homeless boy Hello, someone, please
come in the convene.
No one comes in the convene.
In 10, 9, 8, 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 3, 2, 1.
Oh, get store closed.
Sarah's store is closed now.
Sarah, no, no, no.
We're closing up shop.
Please leave.
Oh, no.
Would you look at the type?
Hello.
Welcome to our store.
Oh, mystery man.
Um, call me and need me anything.
Not much of a talk.
Huh?
Yeah, if the customer is 15 minutes late, that means I can
leave.
What is he going to get?
I'm going to order.
Uh-huh.
Yes.
What is it?
Ah!
Um, can I help you?
He just nodded.
Maybe he can't speak.
Okay, I'll count that as a yes.
You need a recommendation?
You need me to recommend you something?
Oh my god.
Oh my, I'm kidnapping him.
He's going to watch me play.
be a convene worker he's got to know how to make money all
right
he's got to learn bring your dog to work day it's bring your
dog to work day he's got to learn where all that expensive
dog food is coming from are you looking for something
specific then nods approvingly but i'll do my best to help
you.
Let's figure out what you want.
Okay, is it baked good?
You want something from this shelf, right?
Nah, it's approvingly.
Alright, yeah, let me...
Is this the right one?
Oh my god.
Okay, my...
My stream deck might not be working right now.
Are you looking for someone sweet or just pailing baked
products while I need sweetness to them?
Okay, that doesn't work.
You want something sweet?
Oh, he's not sure.
Crunchy?
I look for crunchy.
Crunchy is soft.
Okay, both crunchy and soft.
Okay.
Alright, I think I got it.
I'm bringing the product I think you're looking for.
Alright, I can only use one hand right now.
Because he's on...
He's currently on my lap.
It's not very convenient.
Okay, crunchy and soft.
What's a popocu?
Tejo.
Rice.
I guess croissant.
Croissants are crunchy and soft.
Right?
Yeah.
That should be fine.
I have no idea.
If any customer wants me to recommend stuff on that shelf, I
have no idea what that is.
inspect oh yeah i forgot about inspecting stuff i've just
been like okay that brings you a touch a flaky buttery okay
that's not very helpful but i'll take those oh well i took
two of those apparently okay oh fuck okay
rotate one hand gaming right now mysterious Matt give me a
sec I'm a dog here right now oh my god he's actually blocked
give me his and let me look at this mysterious man I need to
look at the shelf okay there we go a wholesome bread for a
rich higher taste a rustic addition to your breakfast or
touch a traditional all of this kanji toast.
What are you looking at?
Dad.
Okay, it adds a cultural taste.
Okay.
What is about this?
Fluffy and soft bread.
Perfect for sandwiches or light breakfast.
Yeah, I think it's the croissant.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, it's the croissant.
I got you.
Here's the croissant.
But you're not barking anymore, huh?
You're not barking anymore, huh?
Here you go.
I hope this is what you wanted.
He looks satisfied.
I'm glad I got it right.
Is that it?
All right.
You can just walk me to the cashier real quick.
I'm cool with that.
I just...
All right.
You can bring me to the cashier.
Oh, another thing?
What's wrong?
What's wrong, sir?
Excuse me.
Do you need any help?
What can I help you with?
Are you looking for something specific?
Okay, I'll be happy to help.
Okay, do you want a ready meal?
Okay, you want some pre-made meal.
I'll write this down in my notepad.
Could be a useful clue.
understand what exactly he's looking for affordable or more
expensive and expensive okay so he wants something expensive
why would you come okay i guess i mean pre-made meal
expensive pre-made meal it is a convene so it's fine meat or
fish does it contain any kind of seafood not it's
approvingly so you're looking for something that contains
either fish or seafood all right i got you
i thought like this would be a convene simulator so like you
know like uh it's a supermarket simulator and stuff like tcg
card simulator i didn't realize i'm doing where's waldo but
with food
all right
only gary is super cheap so i don't think it's the only gear
it could be this yeah that has to be the bento is more
expensive than only gear It's cute.
It's a cute game.
I went in blind with it.
Because I thought it was like a convene simulator.
So, I'm pleasantly surprised.
It has a lot of story to it.
Like a little detective game.
But with food.
It has to be this.
At least I don't have to worry about food going bad.
That is literally our only bento too.
I miss I miss Asian kameenis
Alright Here you go Here you go I hope this is what you
wanted
Oh But he was looking for something else What else would you
want?
Only Geary's are so Are cheap
A perfect Yeah none of this says expensive
This is a snack, sir.
No, he wanted something expensive.
He's like, I don't want anything inexpensive.
Oh my god.
Don't tell me it was the Tempura of Bento.
The Golden Shrimp.
Didn't he say he wanted something expensive?
Say he didn't want anything inexpensive?
Like, do you want it inexpensive?
And he's like, no.
Oh my god, how is I supposed to know shrimp?
I don't know if shrimp or salmon is more expensive.
Oh shit, sorry.
I'm a dog.
I'm like, oh, what are you looking at, dad?
He's just sitting on my lap right now looking at me.
I don't like it.
Am I disturbing your sleep?
Maybe.
Maybe you shouldn't be.
barking because I'm working right now.
This is what happens when I'm working.
It's just like, wait, this was a bad idea.
He's like, look at me.
He's like, can't sleep.
Alright, okay.
Come on.
Alright, back down, you go.
Alright, you can leave now.
think this through he's like wait a minute not fun it's not
fun on on the lap i'm trying to figure out what he meant
what did he want like there's no prices on here oh wait
there are prices on here or a hundred oh my god it was
literally 50 yen more expensive are you fucking kidding me
oh i'm I'm so sorry for not getting you, like, the most
expensive, the 50 yen difference.
Are you looking for something specific?
Let's figure it out.
House cleaning?
You want something to clean your house with?
Okay, no.
Are you for personal hygiene?
Okay.
Is it for your body?
No.
Okay, for face or aura?
Is it toothpaste?
Oh, that's good.
I better write it down.
Let me guess.
Are you looking for...
anchovies.
Okay.
At least it's not anchovies.
Alright.
Okay.
He is looking for something on the face.
That's paper.
Mouthwash.
Oh my god.
It could be anything.
Wait.
Is it mouthwash or?
Because it's not body.
So.
A gentle cleansing cream.
Enriched.
We're removing makeup.
Yeah, okay.
Moisture balance.
Is it facial?
There's no facial mask here, though.
There's cleaning gloves.
There's paper cups.
But yeah, okay, definitely not the tights.
Could be hair.
Could be shampoo.
I have two hairs, though.
Oh my God.
I've asked the wrong questions.
These are not...
Those were not good questions to ask.
Oh my god, I wish he can just speak to me.
I don't want to make sure there's anything back here I have
to look at.
No, shampoo is hair.
Body wash is for body.
Or I might have to ask some.
It's not...
Alright, never mind.
What the fuck?
It's too vague!
Hygiene.
I guess mouthwash is hygienic.
He said it was something with facial...
Okay, I'm going for mouthwash.
That has to be that.
If it's not that, then I guess you should have said
something else.
There's a toothpaste kit in the fridge.
Check the fridge for toothpaste, dokey.
all right
i assume it's math wash but here you go sigh oh my god we
have one of every oh my god all right fuck you man he sighed
at me how do i even open my notebook too anyway he said like
i can look at my notes Oh, I'm sorry for not reading your
fucking mind, bro.
I swear to God, if there is...
Oh, my God.
Who puts toothpaste in the fridge?
Who...
I thought he was...
I thought he was fucking with me.
I thought that dragoon was...
Oh, my God.
The premium sushi socket.
We found it.
The cold toothpaste.
Now we know why he was mad.
Ice cold, minty toothpaste.
We never lied.
How was I supposed to know?
That he stored the fucking toothpaste next to the ice cream.
that dragon was the one who was working there before you
oh my god please for the love for the love of me i don't
know i don't know what dad's barking though
dad i swear to god i'm trying to beep poop right now oh hey
it's how did is this it's a oh hey it's shonen jump Or
Shouju.
What is the other?
The women equivalent, the female equivalent of Shou and
Jump?
Where Oran was serialized?
All scanned.
That would be a thousand two hundred.
Two thousand.
Okay, eight hundred.
There.
Oh, thank God.
There's a hundred yen bills.
That's your change.
I hope you enjoy what was picked.
Another happy.
customer thank you for your purchase oh you found everything
you were looking for please come back again soon is he even
listening to me another happy customer oh shojo b yeah shojo
b yeah that's what i was thinking of okay that was a bit
strange what should i do now i can keep restocking the
supplies there are also some tasks on the information stand
i didn't do yet Or maybe I can just pass some time until the
next customer arrives.
You're right.
Should I go in?
Alright, let's take 5.
The entrance doorbell will let me know when the next
customer comes in.
Alright, guys.
Bathroom break.
Whoa!
Time to go on a bathroom break till the next customer.
Tokey Broke Another bathroom break Alright let me Alright
The ride never ends
Another bathroom break guys Job well done Good job Tokey
Good job Tokey Try someone new?
Or do we go full in on the bone?
I must reach...
Yeah, I got...
Wow.
It was so hard working today.
Serving my one customer.
I hate the witch.
I hate playing Giovanna.
Her...
The cats are not it for me.
Really?
Giovanna with Tomes go hard?
She was so frustrating to play.
Because of the cats.
It was so frustrating.
I was not having fun with it.
You could buy a new... Which one?
What else?
What else other than the... Oh, I could try the dog.
Let's try the dog.
Let's be the dog.
Alright, where are we?
I believe in the bones.
Oh, we're gonna believe in the dog.
Okay, it's here.
This place.
Alright, go full and blind with the dog.
This could be rough.
Maybe the dog ain't so bad.
What does the dog do?
Fire three more projectiles.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
See, it ain't so bad.
How many, what cards do I need?
I guess more ones or zeros.
We're gonna go with zeros first.
And then grab another.
Oh my god, bone!
Guys!
everything stop what you're doing right now there's bones in
this game stop everything guys there are bones in this game
it's perfect stop what you're doing
bone you can never escape bone down I'm gonna keep the that
guy Oops, did not mean...
Oh my god, I have 105 HP.
Oh, no.
Oh, this is not good.
Okay.
I need that.
And then...
Get the bone in.
But dog and bone!
What more can you want?
It's the best of both worlds.
Oh, it's right here.
all right bone
all right the best of both worlds
like this isn't coming no it is I just went I'm just on my
bathroom break right now guys okay we need the dark heart
for the upgrade I don't know what you're talking about I'm
just on my bathroom break
all right we got five percent left we got the I'll grab the
hollow heart just because we need it for the upgrade.
Zero, one, two, whip.
Nice.
All right, now we can do the upgrade.
Okay, we got the whip with the heart.
Now we have bloody tear.
I have not...
I made it really far with this guy, but then the damage was
just too much.
Damage went fucking crazy.
It will grab XP, though.
We really need XP.
I'll get as many cards as I want, so I can start whipping
the goblin.
Yeah.
Alright, we're going to whip the goblin soon, guys.
Do not worry.
Oh, times two.
Put it on the flowers.
Dogs got something for you
Oh draw Put on the bone Okay I made it really far in this
one area with the XP buff too So it's gonna be interesting
without it I don't know we can do it without the XP buff
That's what I'm worried about the most
All right, zero, light tone.
All right.
Light tone.
Flower.
Zero.
My little heart.
Another heart as well.
Uh, zero.
One.
Oh, oh, oh, you want to fight back?
Oh, you want to fight back?
You think you can fight back?
You think you can fight me?
Oh shit.
I was like, get out of here!
I'm gonna send you back to hell.
That's right, you're gonna be a fallen angel.
Lucifer's gonna have another angel down there soon.
Okay, grab a double here.
Whoops.
I'm doing it out of order.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
He's picking up too many cards right now, so it's fucking
with me.
There's so many cards.
Oh, he is taking way too long to die.
This might be bad.
I might need an armor tome.
Or an armor card.
He is taking way too long to die right now.
good how
is he still alive i've just been whipping him non-stop okay
there we go yeah i was gonna say how much more do you want
wait do we want duplicator or bible yeah he's very tanky
I want a duplicate or a Bible, yes.
Uh...
I'll go with Foot Luck, No.
I go with Duplicator, you're right.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I'm going to grab armor.
We actually need armor.
Alright, knock, knock.
Oh, an easy combo.
I'm going to put it on.
I'm putting on the flower yeah
I'm thinking about duplicator because I'm throwing
projectiles all the time yeah there
you go times five combo nice goodbye that's right I told you
I'd go to heaven one way or another I'll force myself up
there You can't stop me!
Okay.
Let's go.
I did play Mega Bunk, and I also got equally addicted.
I reroll.
Let's grab the crown.
We need the XP boost, anyway.
I don't think we're winning this run, though.
I will be honest with you guys.
This might be difficult.
This...
Alright.
Since we got a little high.
Only because like these guys are like, oh fuck I messed up.
Only because I'm not doing as much damage as I should be
right now.
They should be dead by turn one.
I won't take anything else.
I should even have a turn.
Oh fuck, I should have done a combo that.
Alright.
Sacrifice the card.
Yeah, permanent stat boost.
Wait, I just want to cash out.
Uh...
Crossword.
Wait, how many cards do I... I don't know.
I wish I could tell... I wish I know how what cards I have!
Uhhhh...
Grab two.
And that's my only gripe.
Sometimes you don't see the cards you have.
Like, I don't know what I'm playing sometimes.
Oh, growth.
Put it on the empty toe.
I want to be able to see my deck so I know if I want to
upgrade something particular.
all right let me look right now that is not 13 cards there's
two four six eight dead oh it's 13.
all right we have also i don't like how it's not number
ordered so i don't know if i'm like if i have more zeros or
ones yeah i wish i can like i wish it's ordered by numeric
numerical so i can tell if it's what if i have like any more
zeros ones or twos i think i need more ones Yeah, I need
more ones.
For sure.
Yeah, that.
Now I have a little heart.
Oh, shit.
Okay, yeah, no.
I think this run is already dead, guys.
No, this...
This run is not looking so well.
It might be dead.
It might be a dead run.
Ones.
Yeah, I remember now.
Oh.
Zero, one...
Two combo.
The bathroom break might end soon.
Okay, nice bone spellbinder.
Because I'm not doing enough damage, I don't have enough
armor right now.
Fuck, do I... I'm coming into the armor.
Yeah, I knew he was going to hit me.
Okay, 2,000.
Okay, I still have enough armor.
That's good.
Zero, one, two, wings, bones.
Grab two duplicators here.
Zero, one.
Oh.
Oh, can I put one twos?
4,000, obviously.
Yes!
Give me that heart.
I re-roll.
We need ones, right?
I guess we'll get a Tome.
500 extra dollar runies.
Oh, it's not looking so good.
I lost 10 HP.
Charge won't consume any mana once.
Oh, we want that.
Maybe the cross.
Put it on the cross.
If I had double damage, I would put it on the cross, too, do
not sadly all
right can't let them get close to us okay zero one two I
told you I told you I will get into heaven one way or
another one way or another gonna get gonna get me a
nice free heart is that guy okay oh i'll use it free heart
uh heart i can whip it how does this bathroom break look i'm
the only one look i'm working really hard right now okay
like Like, I'm working my ass off right now.
I deserve some me time.
No, you are not.
Oh, yes, I knew that chicken.
I'm taking way too much damage right now.
I don't like it.
Nice little heart.
This will get little heals with that little heart.
Alright, there we go.
Spell binder.
Get more XP, though.
We get more XP, though.
Playing games are important.
Companize simply.
Yeah, exactly.
I'm just being very...
I'm being immersive right now, guys.
I'm just immersing myself.
Alright.
Uh...
Zero.
One.
2 Oh god, I'm losing so much HP though Okay, zero
Okay, one Two And the flower
Oh shit, oh no, I'm confused I'm so confused Minus one, zero
Flower No damage whatsoever Okay, he does 15 damage.
I need armor.
Someone give me armor!
Alright, that's less damage.
At least.
One.
Two.
That's fine.
I really need the armor anyway.
I need to stock it up.
Eh.
Holy shit, he's so tanky!
oh thank god oh thank god we got him it was so tanky i need
more damage give me that money
uh we'll do evolution we need as much damage as possible oh
wait we need armor we need armor okay armor tomes armor
tomes i need armor cards
okay maybe i have too many armor cards Maybe I...
Maybe... I still need damage, guys!
You're like, armor cards, you say?
Don't worry, we got you!
Say, I still need other cards!
Alright, let's see.
Enough?
I do.
There we go.
Do you think it was super chat?
Thank you!
I have to go to bed now.
Thank you for the nice stream.
Hey everyone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you enjoyed our competing stream.
Yeah, uh, we'll grab the freeze.
So we have a three combo.
It is open 24-7.
I'm just on my lunch break right now.
Oh, I'm getting less and less HP right now.
This is not good.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm losing HP so fast.
Guys, I don't think...
I don't think Doggo is gonna make it.
There's a possibility.
Oh, Doggo, no!
Maybe more bone?
Maybe the answer is the bones we see all alive.
Maybe it's the bone.
Alright.
More bone?
Maybe.
More?
No.
Increase combo.
Doki.
Sometimes the answer might not always be more bone, Doki.
The answer not more bone?
No.
That can't be.
What do you mean it's not more bone?
That's possible?
Is that even possible?
I've never heard such a thing before in my life!
There's no way!
Is such a thing even real?
We'll grab a crown just for the sake of it.
Just for the 430.
30 XP.
Surely something good would come out of that.
There you go.
Are you out of your mind?
How could you say such a thing?
Cross or Crown?
I don't know.
Guys, what numbers are we missing?
You guys are helping me count.
Usually I autopilot this.
What was it?
I don't even know.
Cross or crown?
Ones?
We need more ones?
I'm not keeping track anymore.
I just... Ones.
Okay, we need ones.
Alright.
I'm gonna draw a card.
Oh, gross.
Bone.
Uh...
We'll grab a heart.
And...
S.
We'll grab a bit of spinach.
I don't think we need either of those.
Bombardment.
Alright, let's fuck it.
Let's go bombardment.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
A bombardment.
Oh, no.
This game is really fun.
I've been addicted to a game in a... Like, a game in a long
time.
So I really enjoy it.
Deals bony damage!
you say this the bone fills it's still possible yes let's go
it's still possible
holy they're so tanky okay guys this might be this might be
where we fall
This actually might be where it ends.
Put an axe.
Oh no.
It did a lot on me.
Oh my god, it took half my HP there and just one hit.
It's a little too close for comfort.
I'm getting this guy's out of here.
I don't trust them.
Wings time.
Oh, please don't touch.
No!
Don't touch me!
I thought I banished you, cat!
Okay, we need minus one, though.
Let's get that axe down there.
I thought I got rid of that thing.
Oh, no.
No, it's too, way too close for comfort.
All right.
Grab the HP.
We got that one HP.
Please don't hit me.
Okay.
And then we start back at zero.
Never mind.
We can't.
Could put more bones.
And then grab a fire and then do that.
We draw a card.
We might need to draw a card.
Draw a card.
then we go back we get xp then we bone just throw one bone
in there for fun then we draw a card get the dog in here
nice okay we might not live past this particular stage i am
not very confident The minions are kicking my ass right now.
The minions may or may not be kicking my ass.
2,000 damage.
Okay, that's a lot of health, though.
I do need those.
That has some good ass health.
And we reset the counter.
And then...
Put a 3 in there.
We reset and then...
grab a bird the minions are the customers and are asking me
to come out of the bathroom and I said give me one minute
I'll be right with you sir oh shit there you go nice all
right big boss tab okay
nice okay we have we knocked them down a it okay
we'll grab the 200 and that'll help
all right uh we'll grab another heart there
thousand or bones okay we'll grab that and then bones what
am i saying i can do both there's no such thing as choices
and then we'll grab this
and then draw a card and we'll draw another card
we'll do wings and then
I'm trying to figure out how to count right now and we'll do
that
and this fire one bone, bone and then thunder loop oh my god
18 Okay, 18 damage.
We might need more armor soon.
That one's free.
I like free stuff.
Okay, reset the counter.
All right, draw two cards, please.
Armor, nice!
Okay, that's good, that's good.
That's good.
We need that.
That should came in clutch right now.
Reset.
And a bone.
And luck.
Oh no.
Where are my armors?
I'm grabbing you.
I need to grab the ebony wings.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, this is a lot harder.
I need more armor.
Oh no, oh no, I can only take two more hits Where are the,
okay there's the armor, there's the armor I see it I see the
armor Okay plus two that's good, that's fine That's fine,
that means I can take two more hits again Oh god I need a
brace though for sure
Oh, one more hit I can only take one more hit
oh god no no not the freeze
i live another day i live another day oh let's grab that
armor in here just for safe measure i live for one more day
can't kick me out of heaven yet god can't kick me out i'm
still here still down the cloud let's see I can maybe go
around and just shimmy around yeah what do I not want okay I
don't think I need the clover I didn't get as much mana as
possible okay reroll all right draw one card oh we're just
gonna shimmy around until we find some chicken This might be
how it ends guys
They ain't looking so great
Okay All right, that was 24 armor.
I appreciate that
A bone
Grab this and then we can get that Cherry bomb armor.
Oh my god, we really need armor to more armor guys to more
armor armor.
We do have a re-roll, but armor is actually pretty good for
us right now.
I'm gonna go with armor.
I'm going all in on armor.
We're all in.
640 XP right now.
Chicken.
Oh my god, chicken.
Okay.
Maybe chicken's dead?
Okay, it's fine.
That's okay.
I'm good with that.
I'm okay with that.
that.
Oh, ancient tomb.
I'll grab a three.
I think we need a three anyway.
Oh, God, a brace.
That's good.
Brace is good.
Double damage.
Fuck.
Okay.
No double damage.
Uh.
Do we need more?
I don't know numbers.
Numbers.
Give me the numbers.
Bone?
No.
We don't need my bone.
Let's do one more reroll.
Oh, my God.
Numbers!
Quick!
Quick maps!
Ones or twos!
I'll do two.
Numbers, Tokyo!
What do they mean?
Okay.
I'll grab magic just in case.
I don't know.
This could either fuck up the run or be pretty neat.
Alright.
What?
Oh, it's over.
It may haps be over.
If he doesn't hit me, it should be fine.
He hit me.
Okay.
It may haps not be fine.
Alright, it's okay.
It's okay.
I got 21 armor again.
Uh.
Got the thunder.
I didn't hear no bell I hear no bell
Oh my god
Okay Uh Uh Uh
Okay we bought some time We bought some extra time There's
no question marks anywhere Why are there no question marks
anywhere Okay I'm not fighting for the treasure.
I, like, the first mission is just to survive right now.
And we gotta think about living.
Oh, please don't hit me.
Please just...
Oh, come on.
Don't...
No!
Oh, my God.
3 HP.
3 HP in a dream.
Mayhaps.
7 HP in a dream.
7...
7 HP in a dream!
Alright.
Believe in the bones, believe in the die!
The die will set us free!
Oh no, I don't even know anymore.
Just do the spicy damage, though.
2!
Oh, I have too many twos.
Why did no one stop me?
Okay.
I may or may not have too many twos right now.
Alright.
We live to fight another day.
Rainbow armor.
Okay, nice.
Okay, the armor.
The armor helped.
Attract another one.
Uh.
Okay.
It's all coming together.
We're going to grab the golden armor just for emergencies.
I'm going to freeze.
I don't trust myself.
I do not trust myself.
Anything can happen.
Let's see.
Okay, there we go.
oh let's continue to believe in the heart of the cards just
continue to believe
okay oh oh okay don't hit me please okay it's fine
okay oh no oh i needed more i needed so much more
pentagram That's good.
It resets.
And I can reset again.
In a pentagram.
What would Yami-Yuki say?
These guys are so tanky.
It's so scary.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I don't know.
Bible?
Bible.
Okay.
And I can heal.
I can go backwards.
and I can heal oh please don't get closer please please
don't get close to me
okay there you go um I might have may or may not have 6 HP
right now I might may or may not have started with a
thousand a hundred and five so um just a A little scary
right now.
A little bit.
Goodbye, doggo.
Goodbye.
You are so strong.
You did good.
My little one.
You did so good.
Wait, now I can buy this.
Where the fuck this is?
Alright.
Wait, guys, I have an idea.
Okay, one more run.
One more run.
One last run.
I have an idea.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, I have an idea, guys.
One last run.
Now that I have two, how do I do this?
How do I...
Hit in.
How do I recruit two?
Oh, my God.
Yes.
now we're unstoppable guys we're gonna be what's hort hurry
what is that what is the hurry
the skeleton and dog the run the duel of the century
oh is it time oh faster animations is it okay we need that
The man's best friend build It was faster animation I like
that Oh my god it's so fast Oh my god it's actually so fast
Holy shit Okay it's Bone Dog
We'll get zero Okay Okay, we need ones.
Holy shit, we're going...
We're zooming now.
Oh my god, I did get...
Okay, I did get like 700 XP too.
Oh, flat freeze.
Alright, crowd.
We need an XP tome.
We're able to get so far just because of the XP tome.
I think that's what like clutch came in clutch for us.
Yeah.
Bone.
Draw card.
We're speeding here.
We're doing a speed run.
Garlic.
We'll get a little heart.
So then we have 75% XP now.
Okay.
Like Tome.
Fashing my head a little.
Okay, let's see.
All right.
a reroll i'm gonna reroll again oh okay we might be able to
grab more boat we might okay all right we'll do that so we
can grab another flower we're gonna do a flower build
what am i looking at okay one two
heart one decrease cart attractor orb oh my God, how many
did I pull up?
Bone.
I just pull up the entire deck.
More crown.
Where am I?
Where am I, okay.
And then 105 XP.
There we go.
What do I need?
Help?
What am I lacking?
Oh, I see.
Okay, zeros.
We need zeros.
Do we?
I don't think we need zeros.
Wait, no, we're good.
We're good on zeros.
Unless we get a zero right here.
Oh, my God.
Speed.
We're going so fast.
Okay, we can evolve.
The garlic.
And now we have so many.
leader.
Okay, we'll pull another card.
Oh, but it's alright.
Okay, weighty tome.
And a soul leader.
And then, bam!
Okay.
Magic.
And then attract.
And then soul.
Oh, doesn't matter.
Okay.
This.
Dodge.
Eat em, beam em, bop it!
Knife, attract,
wing.
Yeah.
Soul leader.
Zero one.
I think we're going fast though.
We're speeding through it.
Oh, shit.
He's going to hit me now.
Nice!
Oh, we did it.
Okay, we'll get another flower just for the love of the
game.
I know this goes with...
Okay, zero or ones.
Chat.
Dragons, zero or ones.
Candle or what or cherry bomb
That's right.
I'll find my way to heaven now cherry bomb
Zero okay, it's two there.
I clicked one Wow makes the card wild.
What does that mean?
What is making a card wild do?
What does it do?
Is it like any card?
Oh, is it like it doesn't any combo number oh all right
which one we won for combo which would be the best for it
though like a two which would be maybe draw one on tomes
should we do the one tome or the zero tome or the two i
guess i'll do the two so it won't cost me anything Yeah.
Okay, King Bubba.
King Bubba.
Sorry, King Bubba.
Wait, where is that?
Not fuck it.
I want a bigger deck.
Okay.
Armor.
Reset.
Okay.
I think I have too many tomes now.
I may or may not have too many tomes.
It's like having too many cooks.
Oh!
DPS.
Oh, that's that.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Oh my.
I just drew 800 cards.
800 car runies
okay yeah attract
oh retain adds three mana I think I have enough mana I think
I should see more draw cards
there we go
I'm so locked in I can't even talk anymore I just cards.
That's my job.
That's my purpose.
I just I pick card up.
I place it.
Stuff happens.
Okay, get this cat out of my game.
go in.
Oh.
I take chest.
I throw bones.
Card comes out.
I pick up one with the card.
I need more armor.
What am I doing?
Oh my god.
Did I just got 80 cards?
What was in my head?
Every time.
Every time I get 80 and get 20 more cards, I'm still
surprised.
It gets me every time.
Oh shit.
Okay, here we go again.
I just never expected Every time Where am I going to put all
these cards
I'm reroll I could get a bird though I could get I'm going
to get a bird I'm getting that bird in You're coming with me
I'm kidnapping you
Alright are all fire.
Yeah.
My neurons are firing everywhere.
I can see I can see seven steps ahead.
I know exactly what cards I'm going to place tomorrow and
the day after tomorrow.
And the tomorrow after that.
It's all coming together.
And it's all cards.
Breakfast, lunch, and dinner!
It's just all bones!
I have ascended.
She has ascended, chat.
She is not part of this world and no more.
Okay.
Let's hope he doesn't make a move because I did actually
ditch the armor.
I thought I didn't need it.
I thought I was better than him.
And I am!
Oh shit, he hurt me.
Guys, he did damage, guys.
That wasn't part of the plan.
Oh my god.
How is he still alive?
The whole world landed on him.
Okay.
Zero.
One.
We need tome.
I know.
How is he still alive?
That's what I'm saying.
Oh, there we go.
We'll grab the axe just because we can.
I think I might need ones.
I'm not sure yet, though.
We'll make the bird free.
Free bird.
you would think that oh my god oops you would think the I
would die faster with me fucking poking is poking it all the
time oh fuck okay that's fine we grab it here oh forgot this
is my oh this is looking a little scary now
okay now it's just what card do i want to play
i'll grab armor i think we need armor
what if more armor oh
i didn't think i get more armor i think i i i I can...
Whoops.
Oh, that's...
Oops.
That's so...
That's a little awkward.
Okay, we gotta grab a zero and a one later.
All I could think about was...
Guys, guys, you have to understand.
Harvard.
I didn't think it would just...
disappear oh
that's bad i sort of needed that
okay oh that was bad i really needed that armor guys okay
there we go there we go um it's fine okay what i did zeros
and ones right zeros and ones we need more of
it's okay it's okay it's salvageable we can salvage this
guys we can fix this we can rebuild
guys what was it was it ones was zeros and ones right or is
it twos i've oh okay oh we could get crowned okay cherry bob
Okay.
All right.
That's a lot.
Oh, no HP.
It's okay.
We don't need it.
Zero.
One.
Two.
Okay, nice.
Re-roll.
Oh, but we could get threes, though.
Wait.
Okay.
3-3-3-1-1-2-1.
Okay, we need...
Okay, yeah, we're...
We might be missing some zeros.
What?
But what about some armor?
You know what?
An armor is like a zero, if you think about it.
Why don't we draw more cards?
Oh my god.
Wait, oh, and a draw card.
Okay.
Oh.
They're all dead.
They're all...
They're just all dead.
Nice.
Oh gosh.
I have to think for a sec.
I'm just processing everything.
As we go.
This might be the run.
Man's best friend.
The golden trio.
What if we have more cards?
But what if?
What if we just keep getting cards?
Can't beat a dog in his bone.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And I just...
keep resetting one two okay they're dead zero one two reset
one reset nothing one more zero one two grab my money back
more armor.
Add more armor.
Yeah.
Reset.
How high can I go?
I think that's as high as I can go.
Wait.
Okay.
This might be as high as I can go.
We'll just grab that in.
Yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, that's fine.
And I can reset it again.
And bam!
And I reset it again!
And I grab this!
And then...
I have more!
And I grab this!
And I reset it again!
And I keep going!
Oh my god!
Let it ride!
And I Oh my god And I keep going Where are my damage cards?
Oh I stopped It stopped It stopped I got lost I actually
lost track of all the cards I'm just gonna I'm just gonna I
don't know anymore I don't I can't Find my cards I'm trying
to find my cards Yes
where are they okay there you go there you go we reset it
all everything is reset now it should be fine there we go oh
there's more all right here you go there's still more all
right let's see this might be it this might be the run Guys,
this actually might be the run.
Okay, we're going to evolve.
We got to grab another zero, though.
Get me in here.
We need another zero.
We're running out.
Oh, shit.
That was just a Yuki.
He didn't he was so lucky he had the eyes shit
If he didn't have the power of the eyes it would have been
all mine
Yeah There we go That should be it
All right chest oh my god the refund oh my god Give me that
refund.
At this point, they don't even have to give me a mana bar.
All right.
Oh, when did I get more?
Okay.
Minus one.
Just send them in.
Fuck it, just send them in.
And then...
There we go.
Mana is no longer a constrain.
It's no...
I am freed from the powers of mana.
What number do I need?
What number?
Zeros!
We need to find zeros!
Okay.
There we go.
Yes, zeros.
I keep forgetting zeros is the golden number.
Two.
and then we'll have that and
then we can reset here and then we can reset again and then
bam okay zero, one, two reset, refund four
one two two
Okay.
It's fine.
I still have 16 more armor.
None of this worries me at all.
Don't send that in right now.
Oh, nice.
Zero.
Oh my god, there we go.
We got a zero.
Give me that money.
Money, money, money.
Ooh, Big Bird.
Wait, I can copy a card.
What if I copy more bones?
Oh my god, which one?
I can have a big bird though.
Oh, but then the refund!
The refund is so good!
Okay, but no, I'm doing it.
Okay, we gotta get zeros, threes, and fours.
Zeros, threes, and fours.
Zeros, threes, four.
Okay.
Alright.
Zero, oh four.
Okay, sorry, that's not...
Four.
Okay, 0, 3, 4.
I'm talking in code now.
Oh, I'm broke.
What is she speaking?
3.
Okay.
Alright, we got the combo.
Oh my god, do we got the combo?
1.
2.
3.
I'm looking into the matrix and it's staring back at me
Oh fuck I could have gotten I should have done the thousand
edge
Sorry we got the heart though Oh they're getting closer okay
we are we do need more zeros
And then the book
Two oh done Okay Return
Oh, zero.
I'm so locked in, guys.
You don't...
You don't understand.
I'm so fucking locked in.
Oh, okay.
Wait, actually.
Wait, I don't like that it hit me.
Oh, I can't afford it.
And then more magic.
You can start with zero, and then twos, and then dead.
Bones always find the way.
Bones will always find the way.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I almost clicked that.
Oh, I'm running out of money.
It's okay.
Oh, it's not okay.
We got lock-in.
One, two, okay.
One, two.
Three.
Magic.
Heart.
Four thousand.
Oh!
We made it back.
We made back our HP, though.
That's good.
One, two.
Restart.
One.
Oh, oh, somebody touched me.
me.
That's not good.
That's not supposed to come in the plan.
That's not in the plan.
That was a part of the deal.
Oh my god, I'm trying to figure out what to do here.
Okay, water.
And then zero?
Oh, yeah.
Zero.
I think I actually have the god build
Okay Until you just changed it No no I still have it I still
have the god build Believe in it
Oh I can't double Double or nothing I've yet yet to use the
big bird yet out of money.
Oh my god, Pentagram.
Yes.
Yes!
There we go.
I keep trying to do as many cards as possible, and then
somebody always accidentally run out of money.
Eh.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, I don't have a lot of armor, though.
That's not good.
Oh, oh, wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
This wasn't part of the deal.
Oh, I'm sure you sent the water.
Oh, dad, please.
I'm trying to cook right now.
Dad, please.
I'm cooking.
Oh no.
This is bad.
Oh this is bad.
Oh this is very bad.
Oh this is so bad right now.
No he got closer.
No dad this is bad.
Please.
No.
No!
I am...
Oh no!
Oh yes!
Oh, yeah, we just made it.
We just made it.
Oh, my God.
That was so close.
That was actually so close.
Oh, he's believing the art of the guys.
Okay.
Guys, what do you want?
Guys.
What is my deck lacking right now?
Zeros, right?
Still zeros?
Are we still in the zero game?
Is this still the zero game?
I...
There's so many cards.
Oh, why don't we make them blue?
What if my cards are blue?
All right, you're a blue card now.
Congratulations.
You're now blue.
This is bad.
Oh, this is bad.
I counted wrong.
Who, I'm so bad at the counting part.
Okay.
Alright, there you go.
Oh.
Please, I really, really need some chicken now.
Oh, please.
Alright, that's cool.
Oh, nope.
That's alright.
Brace!
Oh.
Oh, why did I pick that?
Oh
There's so many numbers Okay, there we go.
Alright, we made it through another another number day.
We made it through Safe Oh no
There we go
I'll double the
combo And then Do
we put the Put ancient tomb I don't know you got a spot
Okay Okay it's dead Holy shit I'm trying so hard I'm like
there's it's a lot guys it's it's a lot it's a lot of cards
not gonna lie it's it's a hefty amount of cards
I'm gonna risk it I'm risking it for the armor I I got too
scared
Okay.
Whoa, whoa!
Three.
Four.
There we go.
Heal?
Heal.
I think I need the heals the most now.
Oh, no.
What do I do with you?
I guess that...
Oh!
Oh, no.
Oh.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right.
What can we mirror?
What is worth mirroring?
I guess the Celestial Dust.
Oh, my God.
Maybe the...
This one.
This has come in clutch so many times.
The Double Weighty Tomes.
Yeah, yeah.
The Wild Tomes.
Oh, my God.
The fucking Grim Reaper is here.
he's here now
all right that's right he was here he was here Jesus
Christ Pentagram oh fuck okay okay we gotta reduce a mana
cost for him something maybe the ancient home or the bird
ancient home i'm gonna do it less money
zero one two nice
i want to grab as many as i can oh my god but i can have
copy copy give me as much mana as possible we let it ride
please tell me there's a chicken okay there is oh this is
the last one all
right nice
oh we don't have any magic left wait this is so bad
okay we made it to him though we made it to him Oh, this is
bad.
This might be bad.
Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
How much more damage does he want?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh my god.
I did it.
Oh just a casual 22k.
Oh my god.
We fucking did it.
Let's let him ride.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Yeah.
Just a casual 22k right there.
How much damage did I do overall?
Yeah, just with me and mine's best friend.
We got into heaven.
All we had to do.
We'll just kill a couple of angels.
This should have evolved.
I think I got all the evolutions.
Was that the last level?
There's still more!
Alright, we're good.
I'm good.
I don't know, stream in 30 minutes.
Alright, guys.
What a great convenie.
I'm sorry.
I know I said.
I know I said I wouldn't play.
Hey, it worked, though.
The stress test worked.
Guys, it was so immersive, though.
Hi, Doki.
He's my birthday, dude.
Can you have birthday wish on this cool convenie stream?
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you technically
wait wait wait oh bathroom breaks over guys let me oh give
me a sec give me a sec oh wait i rebooted i think i closed
vampire crawlers and i rebooted vampire crawlers give me a
sec but this one thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear fistful happy birthday
to you yeah happy birthday oh man wow just got out of my
bathroom break guys
wow what a what a day So much a hard-working employee.
Wow, me.
Well, good thing I didn't miss any customers today.
I didn't know I didn't.
Anyway, guys, I have another stream in 30 minutes.
We're going to try and finish.
Oh, it's locked.
I did not think I was going to stream this live.
Sorry.
I'm so addicted to vampire clothes.
crawlers.
It's so fun.
I honestly had a lot of fun with that game.
And also a lot of fun in convenience, in, in, in convene.
Anyway guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause to
check up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you set for me, maybe step a little longer because
we're going to be finishing mouse PI later.
Hey guys, I'll see you guys in 30 minutes.
Bye everybody.
Bye.